to sharp
this is the on-time podcast
h3 baby tv on time
you're in trouble
keemstar shut up
[Music]
coconut coconut
coconut coconuts
coconuts picking coconuts
coconuts pick coconuts and barbados
wow
on time baby it's off the rim what a
masterpiece exactly sponsored by harry's
razors welcome to the subscribe like and
subscribe podcast that's right that's
right smash that like button where
you've got to smash that subscribe
button likes i care less about
they do you think the likes help yes
i'm still on the fence with the likes
helping i feel like we figured that out
in summer i forgot what we were watching
and you were there was a youtuber uh a
youtube insider video where they're like
if you dislike we'll show you less right
and that blew my mind you didn't say
anything about likes but anyway like you
know
smash that like button yeah you know
where you think we're beg i'm begging
you i'm on my knees
what do i have to do i'm on time i mean
for christ's sake subscribe like
we're here doing the bare minimum i've
done everything
come on what do i have to do hey i'll
tell you what you go ahead and like that
button and i won't come to your house
you know what i'm saying oh no it's too
early i tell you what
maybe you hit that subscribe button
i'll look the other way on you
a little
doing something for me and i'll do a
little something for you your little
baby sister been looking nice lately be
ashamed if something happened to her
that's what i do
so hit that like button and nothing bad
happened you know what i'm saying
not a threat
just a fact
bad things happen to people all the time
people get hit by cars
people fall on train tracks it happens
the bottom line is you cannot be trusted
so unless you want some you know i'm
just saying something bad might happen
i've been in jail i know what it's like
you think i'm scared of that come on
come on gabe
talk to me nicely
all right what do we got here at the top
we got a lot to talk about today
so much we got two more so let me ask
you guys you actually put this in the
document huh
this tiny little image
so we also put you know i can't click it
right
well the link is in the dock as well
right next to it but i okay but right
like the image is not that useful well i
just
wanted to demonstrate
a little something so this guy is my guy
i love this guy
he's doing like flirty f-boy
you guys love this right we're confused
we were very confused yeah we weren't
sure why you sent it like what what was
the appeal
you don't like it let's watch it first
right here
i see dan laughing well i'm laughing
because i can't
we were all a little baffled that you
said this
really a little bit
what are you confused about
it's just
well i thought you sent it because the
cringe
it's not cringe it's awesome
and that's why i included the screenshot
too he's doing like a f-boy like what's
up baby how you doing i get it i get it
and the lip syncing to cartoon sounds
it's genius it's super funny
i can't believe you guys have been such
haters bro
look at the top comment drink when he
flirts
okay
it's funny i hope archaeologists find
this after society has crumbled
i mean it has four million lives so that
i mean clearly i'm not alone in finding
this money oh i don't think you're alone
i don't think you're alone so let me
tell your guys's taste is too refined
you guys are too comedically aligned to
find the humor in this is that what
you're saying i found humor in it the
humor was that you were sharing these
boomer memes with us in the chat this
isn't a boomer meme this is a this is a
zoomer meme a boomer wouldn't even know
what this was referencing
i mean
they wouldn't even get the joke love is
our resident zoomer and he he was one of
the primary haters i gotta say and you
know he's your biggest fan well maybe
abe is i don't know
i gotta say i think you guys are being
snobs you know i'm calling h3 humor
let's take a poll right out the gate is
this funny or no i think it's great and
i think we all are being i'm surprised
you guys are being hated right now i'm
saying i'm interested in the poll too
because i'm seeing very mixed reactions
in the in the chat it's like half the
audience seems to be i don't know when i
saw it i immediately was like this is
this is genius this is how we need to
make it clear though is it funny because
it's like kind of cringe or is it funny
because he's making noises with his
mouse
why would that be funny that he's making
noises with his mouth is it a good dude
is it good or not i mean you guys really
being so haters i thought it was comedy
gold personally i thought thank you
secretary and cam he worked on for adult
swim this man knows comedy he knows who
are you
what exactly are your credentials i
wasn't the one who brought it up no i
see you nodding over there in agreement
with dan
who are you to judge it it just caused
confusion
some of us thought maybe you thought he
was like making those noises with his
mouth
[Laughter]
yes or no tick tock funny
yes
no
ask the question this guy's got a bunch
of classics y'all are [ __ ] haters on
a new level the yes
because i find it
funny
but it's sort of like it's a meta funny
it's funny because you shared it it's
funny
here
come on dude that's hilarious
okay sixty percent said yes so you all
can just take the l fair enough
oh wait
it's growing though no it's growing this
one's not doing it for you guys eh
really not funny it's a it's a it's a
parody of these of these f boys who just
yeah i i i feel that it's so funny it's
so funny and it's original laughing it's
not funny
it is funny
[Laughter]
also he's so good at it he like nails it
you know how hard that is
like do you know how hard that is dan no
i i don't know how hard that is that's
true
some of them are really complex i gotta
find
like here this one has 19.
that's just the one i we watched yeah
it's so hard to lip sync and he's doing
it to cartoon sounds like y'all
literally
have no respect for art
[Laughter]
i i think it's funny okay zach's coming
around cameron's coming around it's
funny it's not the funniest thing but
it's funny it's immersive i didn't say
it's the funniest thing
when they come out here saying that's
the funniest thing ever made
would i say that you didn't so i know
who the haters are it's obviously a b
ian and dan no surprise wait i didn't
say anything yeah but he said there was
confusion in the office if zach and cam
like it who's left
who's left
speak up haters
i wasn't consulted about this
what are you afraid of yeah well you're
being consulted now what do you think
ian thought yeah you were consulted we
said thoughts ian thoughts
i mean i don't
i don't think it's like super funny but
i think it's a thing that makes me go
like
interesting and for that
that there's value in it the exact thank
you see that that's at least like
it is interesting it's
why the hell can i find i thought you
had them pinned do you not see pinned
ones on the
uh maybe not on desktop nah it doesn't
work on this
that's
their desktop because
let's because let's be honest his other
ones have like 400 views they're just
total flops
so
because he's got the ones where he does
the cartoon
voices
and they have like 100 billion views and
then his other ones have like five views
and that just shows the genius doesn't
it folks
what's the video that lives
so it looks like we're winding up
it hasn't moved in a while we're at 58
percent to 42 so it's a it's a little
divisive but the yes is happening
here
[Music]
come on that's that's funny i'm laughing
dude it's so ridiculous
[Music]
how's this a boomer meme you guys are
you guys are wrong
all right well i'm glad that at least 58
percent of you stand with me
stand with me i'm being invaded by the
hostile powers of dan abian
and dan and av is the only ones left
okay boomer it's just dan dan was the
only one nobody else confused
what
y'all everyone else was like it's
interesting it's funny because they're
[ __ ]
they were talking confusion about
confusion what you got here dude see
that's bad [ __ ] that's what i'm saying
speak up haters
i didn't i didn't speak on them so you
[ __ ] little
you weasley little liar easily little
liar dude
holy [ __ ]
just speak your mind baby
also everybody in the chat letting us
letting us know about ethan's hat we
have eyeballs we we see that oh yeah
i'm like all keyed out so
i don't know why i didn't real i have a
lot of clothes that i can't wear because
of the green screen and today i was just
i felt good i had like a fresh fit on
and you he walked in and i was like uh
you are wearing an entirely green outfit
my man and he's like i sure am i was
like yeah baby it's hip-hop i'm all
matching do you see it does it bother
you guys the hat because i can take off
if it's annoying to look at
but my hair is even crazier
i can grab your hat if you want look at
that mop what you want a hat a black hat
what do you think hair or hat there got
your hat here
carrot love is
love is hair i love the hurt thank you
thank you love got your [ __ ] hat
all right this next story is so good i
mean i couldn't even believe it estee
lauder fires a senior executive for an
offensive instagram post that's so
offensive and so confusing and so
mind-bending we i can't even imagine how
this ended up on the internet and this
guy was making 10 million dollars per
year right for 30 years he had been with
the company 30-year career ended
overlapping wow 10 million can you
imagine you're making 10 million dollars
a year to be an executive you know what
an executive does nothing
that's the cushiest job in the world
holy crap so estee lauder uh the makeup
company fired one of their senior
executives john demsie for an expensive
instagram post here it is guys can we we
can show this right it's all
yeah can we show this i think so it's
censored in the meme
so he straight up posted this wait let
me show a picture of the guy because
this actually makes him funnier
uh
john
dempsey
so here's the guy
you know
put together professional
the guy's crushing it 10 million dollars
a year
sitting on top of the world right yeah
okay well here's what happened he posted
this to instagram
it's big bird with a mask
and snuffalophagus in bed sick
my n word snuffy
done got the rhona at a chingy
[Laughter]
why did he do this
well his explanation makes no sense too
so here's the statement now you guys i
didn't know what changi meant what is
a rapper he was popular like 2004. so
why why is it funny that he got it at a
chingy concert the fact that it says
[ __ ] concert makes it ten times more
bizarre and ten times more funny for
some reason
it's just odd that would be so odd
it's just odd
so here is his uh
apology
um
i am terribly sorry and deeply ashamed i
heard so many people when i made the
horrible mistake of carelessly reposting
a r word meme
without reading it beforehand what is
there to read bro it's literally just
do you usually just post stuff like that
fast it's like you went oh
post okay
like if you don't read it what's the
joke i still it's just a like
weird random
without reading it there are not enough
words to express my sorrow and remorse
not only did i hurt many people who
might respect the terrible smack that i
made it's underlying everything i'm
working for my 31 years career the meme
is the furthest thing from what i stand
for and i should never have reposted it
why did you
what did you think it was i'm so sorry
that i let down the company that i've
dedicated my life to
i hope that in time people will judge me
not for this awful mistake but my
lifetime of words and actions which
demonstrate my respect for all people i
kind of feel bad for him to be honest
reading that it's like
i don't know what he was thinking
posting that but he's like how do you
ruin your whole life
how do you try and pass it off that you
you didn't i mean there's there's like
eight words on the meme like it's the
entirety of the meme
so how did he not read it
i'm still confused by the whole thing
i guess i did something to piss off the
instagram god
how do you go home to your family and
tell them you lost your job over a
chingy meme
do you think he should be fired for this
i think he got set
he got put on leave
um
i
i don't know i mean maybe
when you're the executive of like this
this estee lauder company i looked them
up earlier
you know they're they're huge like huge
huge company
uh yeah i mean their stock is currently
trading at two hundred ninety one
dollars a share did he dip it with the
snuffy film that's a good question
actually let me look you cost a billion
dollars
they're up two percent today uh yeah it
was a good day on the stock market yeah
so um
but yeah i mean if you're like
you do need to represent your
giant company a little bit better than
that i think
i'm just going to be [ __ ] posting what
do you guys think let's take a vote
should he be fired yes or no uh okay
i'll put it to about i'm actually
curious what y'all think should he have
been fired over the jingy meme yes or no
clapping if he should suffer he clapped
he was just suffering
should he die clap if he should die
so that's what i thought the chingy
thing was like a
anti-asian thing and then it made sense
like and then it was really bad
so
well that was my first day because i
didn't know who jenga was and i was like
oh that's horrible i know it's a very
old rapper the last time i've seen him
was in an episode of george lopez
that doesn't make any sense
it's just thank you the nose have it i
agree yeah i actually agree i don't
think this guy should lose everything
for this put him on leave
it was just a weird thing like i didn't
even get it and he's 65 i mean
definitely
yeah he's ready to retire
yeah and also maybe i don't know i don't
know how you don't read it at all though
i don't know how that happened but
boomer [ __ ]
man he's the only one who remembers who
chingie is apparently right
i'm looking at his instagram right now
it's all weird boomer memes too
almost entirely
wait let's pull it up link me that let's
let's browse
i have a sneaky suspicion that he
actually saw that that word was in there
and he thought it was okay to post
anyway
i i have to assume yes because
the explanation i didn't read it
dude nobody looks at his he's this this
post has 70 likes this guy is posting
for like his grandkids
that's it
like bruh
no he doesn't think anyone's reading
this look at this 300 likes where did
you we go wrong nora i'm not nora
you know what i'm saying this guy
doesn't know what he's doing
look at this i like dogs i like look at
this meme here
i like dogs and maybe three people
quality relatable 500 so i don't think
he should get fired the man doesn't even
know what the hell is going on
i i'll tell you what he shouldn't have
an instagram though he he's not ready
for all this andy this is actually his
job
this will get paid 10 million a year to
do fake hair starter pack
okay
100 likes right
[Laughter]
someone in the chat said he deserved to
get fired for that dumbass lie that's
that's kind of what i agree too it's
just like the explanation is kind of
what pushes it over the edge to me
here's another sesame street meme
all of my stuff was repossessed
97 likes do you see what i'm saying oh
because the garbage man emptied the
garbage that's that's cute
i'm just saying i'm just saying just
saying
i'm looking for more racist ones they
would have found it already
yeah well you know here guys 80 likes i
am from holland isn't that viewed yes
now that's dog [ __ ]
top reply why didn't this get you fired
chingy responded
yo he made a video on instagram saying
he wasn't offended and he thinks it was
just an honest mistake
yeah
chinky's coming out in support guys
yeah let's go to chingus
somebody else has a good point if he
can't read a meme he can't run a company
true
that
that is kind of a fair point
there's a basic level of competence uh
being displayed here or lack thereof wow
the man's job
if anything
is to exercise good judgment right yes
that's i think that that is actually a
fair point he's out he's fired
what's up what's up y'all
y'all want to know what i'm doing why
everybody's gossiping talking about i'm
trending around the world
over some stuff that i'm not even
concerned about and that i didn't take
to heart that didn't mean much to me
because
i think it was just an honest mistake
that the guy made
i just got off a military tour and now
guess what i'm doing
i'm hanging out with my daughter
while everybody around the world has my
name in their mouth you hear me galaxy
they got your daddy name and they mom
and your daddy's just chillin with you
just to give you the luscious give me
the luscious come on give me the
luscious give me the luck okay i don't
um
it's odd
but in short our boy changi not offended
but i think you're right fire him for
poor judgment
i mean
it's also like
he's an executive who's getting pinned
in 10 million dollars a year he'll
probably land on his feet right you know
it's well those can't feel that bad for
him those executives just go from
company to company
yeah it's crazy this whole inner circle
of executives
i don't know what they do or who they
are
but they go from company to company they
get jobs so easily and they make
millions it's
it's baffling
what does an executive do
that warrants that level of pay
what
um you're an executive of a company are
you not i'm the owner oh
i mean those guys don't do they don't
own the company [ __ ] i mean you but you
employ some executives i i would hope
that you think that they're doing
something
um
i wouldn't call them an executive that's
such a nebulous title
all right
but there's like a you have a cfo right
like or or uh yeah ceo and everything i
mean those are executives
of i know it's it doesn't feel
comparable because teddy fresh is a
small business compared to you know a
giant public company well you think of
like film companies they have executives
but it's not like head of production or
head of whatever that's just executive
um right
no i mean they usually they usually have
what would you say
all right whatever maybe i'm wrong i
mean far be it for me to defend uh you
know overpaid executives um i don't know
why sticking up to them yeah too much
too much wine i must add too much water
oh man there's speaking of kev kev um
do we have so frank i'm just going to
talk about this briefly because i know
not you guys don't want to hear about it
i'll probably make an ethan klein video
about it but ryan kavanaugh they trailer
put out their uh
sec filing because as you guys know
they're merging with this small unknown
company so they can go public
and
dude they lost almost a billion dollars
last year dude
the filing is so bad and like hundreds
of millions of dollars just an executive
comp uh
uh
500 million in general expenses and
administrative costs
dude he's broke that guy bleeding
one of the one of the biggest con men in
history and i say that
without a specific allegation without a
specific allegation it's just it just
has a kind of a
insult to a guy i don't like yes
as a comedian and someone who doesn't
know anything
right
that's pretty good right yeah that's
great
[Laughter]
uh but i mean after he bankrupted
relativity
um i'm surprised anyone gave him money
he got a billion he lost a billion
dollars last year and that actually
explains a lot because i was like
there's no way
he's making money for anyone they only
knew himself they only lost 811 million
that's right i'm rounding up
only only 811.
everybody get your m everybody rush in
guys huge investing opportunity trailers
going public
800 million dollar loss
only ryan cavanaugh could work magic
like that somebody said of ryan kavanagh
he's great
at getting people to give him money or
he's yeah yeah he's amazing at getting
other people to give him money and great
and even better and better losing that
money yeah that's good
firsthand experience
yeah
[Laughter]
yeah yeah it's so great experience it's
it's amazing so that's fun i i i mean i
i'm
no expert on these things but with that
kind of uh
with that kind of loss i mean it's hard
to imagine them existing in another year
or two right that's what i've been
saying i think they're gonna go under
within a year or two but i didn't i
could never have imagined that they were
losing that much money
i mean that is unfreaking believable
holy crap dude
yeah i'm just trying i'm looking at
their uh
c c change that's who they're merging
with
yeah it was some like
a
tiny tech company
yeah i mean they're they're a penny
stock it was trading for like 68 cents
and then when they announce the merger
someone's got notifications
notifications on who did it who did it
who did it who's got notifications on
who did it
just discord on my computer
somebody beeping
it's got to be one of the zoom guys
somebody blowing up
[Music]
who's on zoom cam muted we're both muted
yeah we're both muted who did it i think
it was dan
no last time it was you i said it again
somebody send a
oh send a group chat okay here we go
guys we're going to snuff out the wrap
sometimes it doesn't it only does the
notification sound the first time
we're going to snuff out the rat
here it comes
nothing
there's a ghost in the system ghost in
the shell
anyway by the way since we're on the
topic everyone type rank have it under
the search bar
number two click the website is there
any updates number two
no updates just keeping it uh clean
well just just brush up on your
knowledge
yeah click it from the just google ryan
kavanagh click on does ryan kevin look
like harvey weinstein browse you know
familiarize oh there's this great clip
and that is ryan cavanaugh as a force of
nature
is that harvey weinstein talking about
ryan cavanaugh it's hard to tell it sure
is it sounds
their voices are distinct so when
they're when i can hear them then it's
easy to tell the difference right
yeah
yeah well anyways guys just
tweet tweet the link out send it via
gmail send it to your grandma
post it on your website all that stuff
all that good stuff
by the way triller check this out
oh what what is that it's just a little
qr code scan it
at home yeah does that take you to the
website you just have to scan it and
find out does it take you to uh coinbase
it could it could
everybody get out your phone and go
ahead and
give this qr code a little scan
wait i want to scan it now
i have a feeling i know where it's gonna
take me but
it's not picking it up guys
it's working for me
okay
it's behind me at the moment
okay
go ahead oh yeah it takes the website
so
let's see uh this guy is confusing me
this guy's been on the youtube trending
you know youtube trending page is so
contentious it's always like why is this
guy on why is this person on why am i
why am i not on why am i not good enough
well there's one guy who's been blowing
up on the trending page
named ian boggs and nothing against ian
boggs he's not doing anything wrong no
people are watching his videos and
youtube's trending i mean he's not doing
anything wrong
i mean except making weird i mean not
it's bad content but it's i guess for
kids um
i'll give you an example because they're
all short they're shorts they're
a minute long
so here here's one of them power
contacts early what not fair wait didn't
you hear about the scam that's going
around
well scam instead of giving powers that
can be used for good someone's been
sending out powers for evil man you're
just jealous i'm gonna put these on
whoa these look cool
why is my mom in here hey mom
where did ian go
i'm right here hey mom
protect my shoulder
so i'm invisible and silent
sick
hey mr rogers like you can hear me hey
there kid
wait you can hear me just like i can see
you
um huh
dude so i found out my contacts make me
invisible and silent but when i spoke to
mr rogers he could see and hear me i
don't think your contacts make you
invisible dude why do you say that
you didn't hear
mr rogers passed away last week
huh
i'm gonna have to disagree with you
ethan i think what he's doing is bad
it's real bad i mean he's not a bad guy
i'm just saying like we talk about bad
people you know i'm not trying to like
send hate to the guy yeah
but
i mean it's i feel revulsed when i watch
it but i don't want to pass judgment on
the guy
i don't know what's going on here
what's the common safe
so the eye contact turns in into a ghost
like danny
phantom yep
that was so interesting i want to be
invisible and silent because that way i
don't have to go anywhere 1 000 likes
i mean it's just kids right
it's got to be little girls probably
specifically let this man have his own
netflix show definitely
with a with the with writing like that
with a plot like that
instant hit what the freak yeah you
might as well let j station have a
netflix show right
so this was like number one trending
right and three point five i think it
was number one but it was in the top ten
and number three it kept popping up um
i kept seeing it like week after week
different videos of his and finally i
was just like why why are these always
on trending like what
what is going on 27 million on this one
another super powered one part 13.
what's my superpower today
i can't feel pain it's kind of lame hey
mom oh
marinara sauce
how is that lame
why why would you even say can't feel
pain is lame that's awesome
i don't know
all of these always there's so many
twists and turns like it's it's it's a
whole never going where you think it's
going
he's basically like who's the guy who
wrote the
marinara he wrote the three musketeers
and all those amazing books dumas
yeah alexander dumas yeah yeah they say
he's the greatest storyteller of all
time
he's alexander dumas yeah really tasty
that that was still boiling how are you
not screaming in pain right now i don't
know i guess i have a useful superpower
or something dude you literally just
destroyed your tongue you will never
you're bleeding internally right now
all right well be careful at school
today mom you don't got to worry about
me bro be careful chad's picking fights
with everyone today chad's weak chad's
wikia i'ma hit you where it hurts yeah
oh well blow dude how are you not in
pain yeah are you even human here chad
you need to work out more yeah
hey sarah ian i'm breaking up with you
oh and to make this even more painful
i'm going out with your brother wow
seriously you're not even emotionally in
pain
don't be happy or whatever huh
there's a recurring theme that his
girlfriend keeps cheating on him with
his brother oh really popped up in
several videos which is a little a
little weird 27 million views oh
whoa
he doesn't feel pain meaning his body
can still be harmed just without him
realizing it it's actually more of a
curse oh
thank you 10 000 likes thank you ss the
insane
oh these are just kids these are just
kids yeah it's it's definitely content
for kids i love how chad always says
yeah after every sentence i love that i
like how chad said yeah and after ian
said you need to work out more
how old are these people i mean like
genuinely curious get stabbed didn't
even hurt dies
cool
sonic.exe yeah i mean jstation got like
10 million views on videos too right
like taking this like 10 is this younger
is this eight you know
it does it's a bit older honestly 16. no
no no no it couldn't i think so no no no
no no no shot how could that no shot
your brain can that's too close to a
fully
to a fully formed brain
to be watching this no shot dude no
yeah really sad yeah i'm really sad
james charles target audience basically
well there's a whole bunch of these but
well anyway we recorded uh
some of our old because we're gonna try
to go viral on the shorts i mean with
views like that
you can't
really complain right like
it's kind of unbelievable
let's upload it to shorts and see if we
get the gajillion views okay but before
we do thank you to harry's razors
thank you this march dumped the madness
of your old expensive shaving routine by
trying harry's
betting on the underdog can pay off big
especially with a company like harry's
that teams up the best quality
and construction methods in the razer
game with incredibly fair pricing
i love harry's you guys you guys use
harry i do
and i am a guy who needs on the dome
quite a bit on the domain and on my neck
what do you use
what kind of
do you use any like cream or anything
when you shave i use the hair this thing
oh they nope
no lie i use their little kit it's great
so you put they give you like shaving
gel or foam and you don't you know after
after shave uh
moisturizer oh you have to shave your
dome yeah you gotta take care of that
dome baby i also am a huge fan of the
razors great straight razors well the
thing is that they're just and for women
too i mean i have these razors in the
shower because i shaved the back of my
neck and eli uses them too and she loves
it they're they're just good i mean it's
it's
a great razor
you know it lasts a long time and it's
affordable
i mean what more can you deal with with
that you know
uh
you know
it says how does supporting an
up-and-coming company make you feel
independent how are they up and coming
harry's has been around forever
i'm just saying
i feel great supporting an up-and-coming
company i mean compared to like you know
i don't want to i don't think that they
have been around forever they remember
they they bought a uh a
um razer company in germany um that have
been around since the 1920s or something
used to be in their copy all the time
okay here let me just read this because
they want please blah blah blah betting
on the underdog can pay off big
especially with a company like harry's
that teams up with best quality and
construction methods in the razer game
i feel great supporting a independent
up-and-coming company listen nobody
cares about that it's a good razor and a
great price
that is the number one selling i mean
let's just be real about why we're
buying razors and guess what guys new
customers can get the harry's trial set
for just three bucks
at harry's dot com h3
you're not going to go to a grocery
store and get raises like this for three
bucks that's not happening
even the crappiest razors are gonna cost
you more than three bucks
harry's believes you shouldn't have to
choose between a close comfortable shave
and a fair price so they give you both
in fact terry's blades are designed to
stay sharp longer in a recent study guys
who shave four times a week so their
eighth shape was just as smooth as their
first and that's a better experience
with every shave and savings over time
harry's giving their best offender offer
to our listeners new harry's customers
can redeem a starter set you get the
five blade razor a weighted handle
foaming gel with aloe and a travel cover
to protect your blades when you're on
the go that's a 13 value for just three
bucks there's truly never been a better
time to try harry's go got hairs.com
h3 to try harry's today
thank you thank you thank you mistress
thank you thank you
all right so we made uh
we made our own shorts
what are these you want me to read these
ian you want to do yours first not yet
not yet oh not yet okay so wants to go
first uh
here i have them all cued up in a
playlist here so i can just let them let
them break your eyes go ahead all right
so here's a bee's attempt uh why oh
you're going for the arabic audience i
don't want to go first
well too bad whoa i got these magic
crocs that make a magical coke appear
this is crazy all you got to do is put
them on
whoa
it works
and when you drink the coke and crazy
old air man yells at you
what do you think
it's pretty good i mean yeah i think
these are a little more complex right it
is a little simple there's a little bit
more of a of a thread and a moral story
his things is always careful what you
wish for
yeah i was thinking of doing one where
like you take a pill that gives you
powers
and it's like you could spontaneously
combust like the human torch
but you can't survive it
oh
now why would you want to combust
exactly i mean like the human torch
powers but you're not fighting for me
yeah you're not you're not fireproof
you're like uh
what was the guy from the fantastic four
the human tours
oh that was his name yeah
the human torch and then he does it
right melts exactly
okay pretty good i think i think there's
potential there
the off yell the yelling of the arabic
man off screen was on point for sure he
always says old people voices right
okay
um
zach's uh is next it's a little more
abstract this one but even more abstract
okay
it's time to play wordle let's start out
with great word hello
okay green on the e the double l on the
o
i know what it could be
oh my brother just got home from school
go get a good day oh man my stomach
hurts i shouldn't have eaten that big
ass hot dog i saw on tick tock
and mayo tasted kind of off oh man
toilet is clogged
forgot
why don't they call this game lame-o
nice i should add that one to my
one-liners thank god no timers on this
game oh man it's the poop
you know what i'm gonna go take a [ __ ]
in the bush
man i hope someone saw me i gotta add
that one to the one-liners well i give
up i'll just keep typing hello oh the
word was jell-o i could have never
gotten mad
wow
i gotta say very impressed yeah you like
that it's off the walls
it's pure nonsense
love the internal dialogue yeah thank
you
hitting off i think that that one that
one's kind of a hit i i like it i think
that one could go viral thank you i
appreciate that yeah all right
um here's mine mine is uh similar to
well we didn't watch any of his birthday
ones did we or did we
should i watch one of his birthday
months oh because it doesn't really
matter it's he has a bunch of birthday
ones mine is kind of a parody of that
one or not parody this is very serious
and i hope it goes viral uh one sec here
we go hey big bro did you hear the news
no what's up the ellie lakers just
switched sports to soccer lebron james
is a soccer player now no he's not
soccer player he's a football player no
he plays soccer now
they call soccer football in europe
everybody knows that that's where he'll
be playing wait i thought you said you
hadn't heard about this i hadn't but i'm
wearing my new birthday hat that dad
gave me that gives me omniscient
knowledge of past present and future
wow that's so cool can i try that
no it's my birthday present besides if
you put it on you'll turn into baphomet
the occluded sabbatic goat god of the
night's templar
yeah baphomet you know what just get out
of my room
i can't i don't have weights they've
been replaced with spiders
little sisters am i right
well what do you think
it's a mind bender yeah
i was very impressed by how he he goes
in directions that you really don't
expect and so i really tried to just
kind of i mean the off-camera voice is
spot-on
that was very good thank you i think if
it would have been him as like you give
it to his little sister and then she
gets overwhelmed by the the vast
knowledge of infinite space right like
brain aneurysm
yeah oh because it's always do have
tragedies at the end so yeah always
careful what you wish for right
very good though okay thank you thank
you powerful stuff very good very
complicated working on that voiceover
for a while oh that was you huh
very good yeah so far i think zach's is
most likely to go viral if i had to
guess
thank you anyone else
yeah we got one from ian
fred and i hit a deer on highway 136 out
the dyersville
after i pulled fender rubbing on tyre we
continued to farm
assumed deer dead
i assumed deer dead because it was night
and no carcass
just got word that my daughter wendy
told her car
she's okay
she hid dear dear dead
i learned it was granddaughter shirley
in the car not daughter wendy she is
okay deer's still dead i was doing
morning run at farm
deer killed by car ditch he was dead
seen dead deer on the way to church
they didn't hit my car
unsafe if you drive an area where deer
congregate fred driving me
he said tuesday before new year day he
hid deer
don't have to assume anything he told
dear dead
i wasn't with him that night trove on
highway where fred and i hit a deer
no deer this time you of hair rad saying
deer and headlight look it's a
frightening experience where a real deer
is there assume all iowans must drive
with caution wow wow a cautionary tale
to all iowans
a powerful psa
thank you which is
to
be careful for deer watch out for yeah
it's a big big issue yeah it's a big
problem i'm just trying to make sure i
understand yeah yeah yeah it's it's
about hitting i wasn't sure if it was
just about killing deer or no
you don't want you don't you don't want
dangerous it just seemed like with that
many people hitting deer it'd be hard to
assume they weren't doing it on purpose
yeah
so i've got a link there if you want to
click
uh
open that up yeah that thing you popped
open earlier
oh you want me to open the
yeah so apparently we need context for
ian's yeah i mean this is kind of
cheating ian i don't think we're allowed
to show context for these but oh okay
i'll give it to you
i was just oh you were just reading his
[ __ ] tweets
what the hell
when you're looking to do something that
like free association uh chuck grassley
um is a good resource to tap so wait
this is an elected official he's a
senator
he's a senator yes
one of a hundred exclusive men and women
that's right to serve our great country
fred and i hit a deer on highway 136
south of tayersville after i pulled
fender rubbing on tire we continue to
farm assume deer did
wow i can't believe this [ __ ]
exists
i assume deer did because it was not and
no carcass this was eight years later by
the way
[Laughter]
they're all over the front he's hitting
deer
on
a weekly basis this guy's killed more
animals on the road than keemstar
he's 88 years old maybe stop driving
oh is he 88
oh my god
it wasn't no dear it was my it was a
child i kept driving
we kept we continued to farm
i learned it was a grant oh no i learned
it was granddaughter shirley in the car
accident not daughter wendy she's okay
the deer is still dead ah what the [ __ ]
i just got word my daughter whitney told
her the car
she's okay she hit dear dead no
presumptions i'm told what in the [ __ ]
bro
this is staggering
good find it yeah well we've talked
about him a few times on the show before
because he had that infamous like really
weird pigeon tweet where he's like found
dead pigeon if it belongs to you come
pick it up
yeah i'm sure they're rushing over there
they're dead pigeon
animals
man this is hella weird seeing dead deer
on my way to church they didn't hit my
car unsafe if you drive an area where
deer congregate iowans need longer
season to kill more oh yeah the man
hates deer that's clearly he wants to
kill all the deer
you heard harold saying deer and
headlight look it's a frightening
experience with a real deer is there
this is chuck grassley
truck chuck but chuck
putting the all the pets and animals
under the grassley
if you lost your pet pigeon
it's dead in front of yard my i will
farm just discovered
here are identifiers right leg blue
2020 3089 auburny 2020 she left leg
green band no printed info sorry for the
bad news this man needs to be um
this guy needs like care like
end-of-life care
not in the senate
wow oh god
[Applause]
he's the goat fred drive with me he said
tuesday before new year day he hit deer
don't have to assume anything
he told dear dead i went with him that
night
what the [ __ ] who are you talking to
get him out of the senate man tired of
these boo these old [ __ ] is that guy
even a boomer he's like three boomer
he's a great generation
he's not like he's too old to be a
boomer even
yeah so i want to do my own uh
i wanted to do try and uh do one off the
cuff yeah let's see can i get the format
and the music and everything
yeah one second i hit deer
the deer was dead
now whose is the deer is this a mine or
the cities here you go i hit a deer
can i keep it
is it mine or the cities
bring deer back home
deer wake up
ruin my whole damn house
so i killed that deer and ate them for
supper
[Music]
that's good deer
okay wait no let me get serious
okay
hey guys i just got a magical shirt i
got a magical beanie
it makes my head disappear and nobody
can see me watch
hey where did they go
i'm right here you [ __ ] idiot
oh wow that's amazing it's a magical
beanie
oh well here i am i'm walking around i'm
going to rob a bank
hey what's that money floating
i'm dead
it's got tragedy
you tried you reached too far
that was good absolutely that was
fantastic thank you guys thank you so
much
you're going viral folks
oh here i've got one mm-hmm okay ready
set him up
hey i'm bill grassley i got a magic
apple when i eat it it turns me into a
deer i love deer
hey where'd bill go
i'm a deer i'm walking on the road oh
[ __ ] that's my daughter wendy
i got killed by my daughter wendy on the
wow that had everything now that highs
lows tragedy comedy thank you
now my daughter wendy put me in the
truck she's eating me
[Laughter]
pretty powerful there yeah
fun
good times
good job guys
it's fun
you know
and shout out to to ian
hogg or whatever your name was ian bogg
bogger hog
the boss hog the boss hog what are we
talking about
bob the guy that we just watched the
boss blog i'm sorry it is the beach oh
that was his name yeah yeah
i hit now who i hit the deer
i'm climbing now it's a cold night i'm
climbing in the deer's carcass to keep
warm
oh wait i got another one i got another
one okay
my name's grassley i'm walking down the
road and i'm freezing cold because my
car broke down
look honey there's a deer
go hurry kill it we need its carcass to
keep warm i stab the deer with my knife
and i climb inside his body it's nice
and warm oh no here comes a buck he
having sex with the carcass and i end up
getting awarded by a big old buck oh
tragedy right from good to bad just like
that trending
it's just like life
just like life you guys it's it's
unbelievable what do you guys want to
pull for
oh
they're saying to pull see who had the
best
one it's not that important yeah yeah
it's not it's not that important
here's how you you express who had the
best one when we uh post them all
make your favorite one go viral watch it
over and over again share with your
friends
we're getting let's not get banned we're
getting number one on youtube trending
come on
can we tell people just to loop it i
feel like that's youtube don't like that
we're gonna post them on tick tock
yeah wait i thought we're gonna do
shorts youtube short do you think tick
tock is gonna share that [ __ ] that's a
youtube short crap
that wasn't fun
he posts all of those on on tick tock as
well in fact the views on tick tock are
even crazier you guys are you see he's
got like 40 million views yeah he has
10.5 million followers on tick tock yep
damn boy okay well let's post them all
in tick tock then and see what happens
yeah
we're saying we're all winners so that's
good oh we're all winners
beautiful we all got them dears
[Applause]
i eat dear forever meal boy
yeah
all right well that's enough about that
eh
fun times good times good times man good
times good
times we have fun on this show don't we
i love to have fun
i love to laugh and i love to have fun
that's right
that's the most interesting thing about
me
i love pizza and i love people
me too
we have a long comment with that pop-up
by the way papa spoke at cpac did you
guys i didn't see much media out of the
cpac was it just a flopparino well it
was completely overshadowed by the
breakout of you know a giant war in
europe but even
i think cpac started the day after the
invasion started so that it kind of got
pushed out of the news cycle but was
there not any good
sound bites i saw a few like cringe
things but
honestly it really didn't nobody cared
nobody cared you know what else is
interesting is going on in the world you
guys remember how the trucker convoy was
such a big deal in canada and they were
coming down to do a convoy in the u.s
yes and and nobody gives you [ __ ] no
they're trying to block traffic in dc by
the way and like the mass restrictions
are lifted so i don't even know what
they're protesting at this point i guess
that's why nobody showed up
i saw an article that like 30 people
showed up or something yeehaw we're
gonna block dc boys
well interesting they maybe they could
collab with the jfk still alive gang and
head on down to dallas i think they're
still down there last i saw
about equal amounts of in there for
like four months i also read that these
trucks were just getting stuck in
traffic and they weren't making it to dc
it's awesome
we're changing the world boy with our
trucks
until it gets hot in texas
so here's a here's a crypto related
story that's pretty fun and interesting
a place called crypto land
which is giving me fire festival vibes
yes indeed first announced on november
4th 2021 crypto land is a proposed
project headed by
cryptocurrency enthusiast
to purchase an existing island in fiji
and develop it into a haven for
cryptocurrency enthusiasts what the [ __ ]
are you talking about
what does a haven for cryptocurrency
enthusiasts look like
a normal place like a resort i don't
know
despite many thinking the video was a
satire
the crypto lamp project is real but
multiple details about the project
raised alarms oh are you serious
including that it was a potential scam
come on they were going to buy an island
in fiji as a utopia for crypto bros
uh it was a scam or if not a scam a
potential humanitarian crisis
causing a comparison of fire festival
so the island
is this island that where's their video
like no
it is right here here it is yeah so
here's their announcement video which
looks like a video game like roller
coaster tycoon like what the hell
so they're trying to launch this in
conjunction with 10 000 nfts 60 of which
would be tied to parcels of land on the
island the nfts i swear to you now are
called connies you know like to con
somebody
[Laughter]
so here we go they deleted it so is the
project off because they erased it uh it
their website's still up
um i tried to join their discord but i
immediately got hit with a link to
verify that i wasn't a bot that seemed
really like i see i didn't want to click
on anything having to do with them so
um i am unsure i don't think um
i i think they've probably cut their
losses and run at this point because
everybody just made fun of them uh for
this
and like the video that we're about to
watch they deleted off their channel but
thankfully somebody re-uploaded it
here's the description the first
physical crypto island the first
physical crypto island
we're building the number one crypto
destination on earth a crypto paradise
where the community can surround
themselves with other like-minded
individuals why don't you just rent a
[ __ ]
event hall at the holiday inn like other
idiots like other freaks with weird
hobbies you're right
buy crypto enthusiasts for crypto
enthusiasts
just ask the furries what they do man
and just like you don't need to go to a
higher [ __ ] i mean peace and love to the
first no they just figured out yeah
exactly
a crypto degen with a crush for crypto
kitties i'm on my way to crypto the [ __ ]
did you just say
i gotta go
hi this is me christopher a crypto d-gen
with a crush for crypto kitties all
right arrest him
[Laughter]
a crush for crypto kitties keep this guy
out of thailand and places like that man
do not fly you know there are a lot of
libertarian crypto enthusiasts so it's
not too surprising
i'm on my way to crypto land the number
one crypto destination on earth where
crypto enthusiasts or crypto landers
like we're called here can meet with
like-minded individuals
and when connie the founder told me that
visionary investors could own a piece of
this unique island i smash bought one of
the 60 exclusive parcels on the
blockchain hills that's how i became a
king this man is dead inside
[Laughter]
crypto lander there it is
you know as shitty as the um
so are you as shitty as the
as the animation is i'm sure they spent
a lot of money on this yeah and it's
like 10 minutes long it's very involved
there's still lots of scenes it's yeah
no it costs a decent amount to put this
together coming to the vladimir club
party tonight yeah just for crypto nft
holders right yeah man
have a nice day soon what the [ __ ] is
that
what is
that you're about to find out thank you
connie why'd you count that's connie
christopher come here buddy
their mascot yeah 50 000 blocks at least
so are they trying to represent that
this is a real thing or not because
lastly check there's not giant humanoid
bitcoins walking around to greet you on
an island
so there's one for realism or not
this seems like a fantasy people are
saying they're very scared
it's terrifying
i hate it
i don't like that
and i mean you got to see here let me
just pull these up real quick
the nfts
because it's that guy so you you could
uh you could own one oh they're selling
the crypt the connie's yep
look how [ __ ] epic they are i want
this one for sure
you guys see how bad people think these
crypto bros are so dumb that they're
conning them with the dumbest thing
possible do you see how dumb this whole
crypto movement is
this it's just devolved into such
dumb crap
it's just uh it's just a fire hose of it
like it's overwhelming and
and you know
i i've definitely soured on the entire
thing
if there is any like one of these
projects that has anything
redeemable about it at all it's
completely overshadowed by
just the absolute deluge of
these you know what i mean like there
are 10 000 of these for every one
potentially interesting you know use
cases well the thing even if there's an
interesting one let's just take board
apes as an example because that's
probably one it's like real people with
a real desire to collect it just turned
into this dumb speculative thing where
it's all about making money and it's not
about like being part of a community or
owning cool art it's all just
speculation it's all about making money
going to the moon baby it's just it's so
stupid dude you know
yo you're in trouble that crypto [ __ ]
yeah i'm totally off on crypto i'm out
we dropped all of our crypto sponsors
as painful as that was to my wallet
i just think it's all a giant scam and
i'm sorry if you're into it
i know it's hard
it's hard once you're investing you
spend as much time as something it's
hard to hear
in fact call in i like to talk to a
crypto bro maybe maybe we could have a
dialogue perhaps
are we set up
having a big joke out of it no current i
don't have the system
crypto and his and his
carlos and his bros were crypto bros
that they did not show well on our show
they never do is the thing because it's
just
there's no substance behind any of it
it's all it's all just smoke and mirrors
i mean it's just get get rich quick kind
of [ __ ] yeah unfortunately when it comes
to these schemes and popular movements
it's always the richest people that are
gonna be making the money anyway you
know garyvee is rich and he's way richer
and none of the people that buy this
[ __ ] are gonna make money i [ __ ]
bet you dude everybody's losing money
you're buying those dumb [ __ ] v
friends the friend
you sell i mean he's still standing v
he's just he's a scammer bro [ __ ]
garyvee straight up
i don't like him at all
ab thoughts
maybe thoughts yeah
uh it's true yeah garyvee is your is
your conscience
i don't think he's a good guy i got a
few kanye's dan
i don't and i'm sorry
no i mean i was never like a huge fan i
mean i like this stuff i like this stuff
and i haven't watched them but i haven't
seen a lot more comments like gary used
to put out a lot of motivating stuff but
more recently it seems like he's just uh
trying to raise he's just chilling yeah
chill it always be chilling
yes [ __ ] off gary just followed the
money he's very money driven he's like
the human embodiment of capitalism
actually it's not even true because it's
like not even capital it's like i get
capital you get nothing
capitalism
implies some exchange of goods or
something
uh now it's just a drawing you get a
drawing
or do you even does garyvee send you the
v friend
no of course not it's literally just the
digital
it's the jpeg that's what you get you
think he you get the drawing hell no
because if you bought or sold the crypto
you'd have to send the drawing with it
right
because gary vee only wants you to and
he only talks about nfts now and the
reason he's focused on nfts is the more
people that buy into this crap and
invest the richer he gets he is so
invested in nfts
the dude is he's talking about nft
restaurants now i mean he's just lost
his mind
we have the video of that let's let's
stick to the point here on the crypto
yeah we're going for now i've been
waiting for you since consensus what are
you a pending transaction or what well i
guess i'm confirmed now ready to become
a crypto land maximalist this is crazy
sir
welcome to crypto land the hodlers of
last resort
[Music]
the holders of last resort
the hodlers of last resort that doesn't
sound good
yeah
dart
[Music]
brilliant hey stacking sounds like crazy
right
honey badger don't care
the community's loving it oh my god i'm
on twitter i can't wait for you to give
me a tour connie what do you want to see
first christopher i don't know let's
start with the best no
i always keep the best for last let's go
leave your luggage in your home first
and then i'll show you around all the
other king crypto landers have been
running like the epstein-style greek
temple where they sacrifice people
yeah here's the best part christopher
this is where we sell human organs
how do you think we pay for this island
christopher through crypto
no
and guess whose organs are next
christopher
yours
you're a young and healthy man your
kidney is worth a million dollars on the
black market christopher you don't need
both
donate it for the island christopher
or we'll be forced to take it from you
from all corners of the world when we
get to the blockchain hills you're gonna
understand what i meant by a first-class
crypto lifestyle man hey martin please
get us a car would you yes sir everybody
is here
wait you got you got it uh cam's got a
theory here
on connie it's just a rip of the fried
oreo mascot
this is the photo i took uh when we went
to venice beach
yeah i remember
yeah
they said they ripped off a terrible and
cursed mascot
looks familiar
where does that look familiar that's
funny this one's fine this one's fine
this one is cursed as [ __ ]
hey why's he have teeth like just weird
the teeth like why are they so detailed
you know
yeah some went wrong with that oreo
and then connie and then he became
connie he got a new job
he got fired from oreo got hired by
crypto island there he is
hi
hi mr adams nice to see you sir did you
have a good flight oh yes excellent
thanks for asking great here are your
keys
not your keys not your bitcoins
seriously
wait
wait not your keys not your bitcoin what
does that mean
i think it's in reference to
like
if
people get their [ __ ] stolen like they
get hacked uh on
oh and they're crypto stolen people will
like sarcastically tell them
like well if you don't have the uh if
you don't have the the wallet you don't
have the bitcoins it's basically telling
somebody that yeah they got [ __ ] which
is like a weird thing
to put in your your ad for for this
scheme okay
i think a lot of crypto brokers also
said that it's not your bitcoin if you
have them on like a an exchange a public
exchange oh maybe it's not okay unless
you don't have
have the crypto on a cold storage like a
usb stick right you're a noob oh yeah
you're a noob it seems like a good way
to to store
your belongings i i if i put everything
i own onto a um thumb drive i'd feel
really good about that actually
yeah tremendous security it's far safer
than keeping it in a bank
yeah yeah i don't trust chase bank
i don't trust chase james b morgan to
keep my bunnies i mean the people that
are true evangelists of this whole thing
at its core is a is a
huge distrust of the banking system and
everything i don't trust chase but
they're not gonna go under
chase ain't gonna lose my money i'll
tell you what's more likely are you more
likely that chase jp morgan goes
bankrupt or that you [ __ ] misplace a
thumb drive right yeah or spill a coke
on it or something yeah yeah you have to
kind of
do a risk analysis on that a little bit
your bitcoin not your keys not your
bitcoin
where do you come up with these crazy
ideas
[Music]
[ __ ]
i'm not gonna tell you where
sir
the lambo is ready
the lambo's ready
to the room to the room not the moon
entering the blockchain hills hey what's
that the vladimir club i'm just so
confused is this a real place or not
because
the whole thing is pure fantasy it's
supposed to be
um
now
apparently they said that they bought
this island but then some people did
some research on it and the island was
like still for sale so the whole way
about the islands yeah so [ __ ] of
course not dude
you think this bitcoin you think you
have sex with this coin mascot does he
have like an
anatomy
uh yes
yes you can possibly ethereum's been
[ __ ]
yo look at this
look at this
this sweet crypto land what is the age
of consent and crypto on the crypto
island
and they responded mental maturity
should be more than enough
no that's not real well
are you [ __ ] me in the tits right now
that's real well the person who posted
it provided like screenshots showing
that they got blocked by them and mental
maturity should be more than enough wink
face that can't be real
please well they're all it's hard to say
their whole benna is like oh we're not
scammers but we know about scammers i
don't know so
well no their whole thing is you can
[ __ ] kids on our island
that seems like based on this if it's
real
nah i mean i i remember this being a big
drama so i'm pretty sure it's real
allegedly holy [ __ ] dude well like i
said a lot of a lot of libertarians in
the uh crypto community
holy [ __ ]
mental maturity should be more than
enough that is disgusting and creepy
this eight-year-old is very mature for
her age
and there's members only club we are
preparing everything for tonight we are
throwing the most epic crypto party ever
don't show the close-up of him like that
so much worse vladimir club
uh yeah the vladimir club vladimir putin
um
and now it's been co-opted by jordan
pearson i just love it the whole thing
is starting as such it should show you
guys jordy peterson is speaking at a
bitcoin convention you just can't make
it up
yeah the thing about bitcoin is that the
wolf culture can't touch it the cultural
marxists are freaking out because
bitcoin is
it's it's it's changing the world
you can use you can create islands where
the age of consent is whatever you want
it's changing the world
big where would we be without
bitcoin it's decentralized
you know
[Music]
you know what i'm saying
you know
you guys want to buy some bitcoin
i was paid in us dollars for the
speaking event by the way crypto's
[ __ ] worthless
i don't accept payment and crypto are
you crazy
i got bills to pay you're gonna pay me
bitcoin are you out of your [ __ ] mind
bucko
i got 12 steps to walking out of here
one i accept usd only
two
only meat for meals
during the convention no vegetables
[Music]
now that's crypto land right there my
dude
that's crypto land
holy [ __ ] that's so funny
i guess if anybody's unfamiliar that is
the uh weird temple building on
epstein's uh island yeah
so creepy
so creepy
well what plus one is going to be
here we are king crypto lenders
territory
and here you have these 60 parcels i
can't wait to get to mine
[Music]
so so they're building you a whole house
too for just for buying an nft they're
going to build you a whole luxury house
well only it's so in the description it
said only 60 of the nft holders would
get
parcels of land so i don't know if
i mean none of this makes sense so like
trying to like suss this out is kind of
an exercise in futility but i think six
like the 60 most expensive nfts would
basically be in access
to owning land on this island and then
everybody else that owns an nft can just
come visit as like a resort
but that's that's
my understanding
but in this video they've built this
house for him to build something so
maybe for vacations but right yeah i'm
here i might never leave i already see
we're gonna have the time of our lives
show me more okay
first stop of the tour this that's it
a much requested one yo i'm gonna need
some more details on that plot of land
[Laughter]
did you how much does it cost for one of
the 60
parcels
so
these these and these connie's i
couldn't find on open c so i i don't
think they were selling them on there
again i think a lot of this has been
pulled um because this was like
um like a little over a month ago that
this went mega viral and everybody
started making fun of for sale because i
really want to know how much they cost
yeah well i think some did but they they
were not selling for much not not enough
to to own a house i think i saw it like
point enough to buy an island and build
60 000 on that
and develop it add them to a resort i
don't think so
you'd probably need like a billion
dollars at least to do all this
maybe more to develop old island
folks approach me saying connie we need
somewhere where we can be programming
surrounded by palm trees and views to
open sea they were sick of working from
tiny offices why do that when they can
work from paradise so we built it come
on in
people are picking up their passes for
the event tomorrow starts the crypto
land blockchain week we organize a
number of different crypto conferences
and meetups year round lots of crypto
vips coming tomorrow you can feel the
entrepreneurial spirit here you can work
get coffee and when you get stressed you
can hit up the distress room
the distress room oh no i don't want to
know what goes on there
i don't want to know what's going on
after annoying that asian consent
comment i don't want to describe
a pool full of coins that's insane don't
be shy go ahead and try everybody loves
it
if you like this just wait until you see
what's next
what are you selling none of this is
gonna exist clearly
this is just this is just
the sims this is how you this none of
this is real
restaurant you're gonna love this
christopher
you little bot
jim any tables available well we can set
up the 12 if you want all righty here we
go
the order oh my god
what was that
she served him a dish that said rat
poison and gave him an ominous order
book for startups i would suggest the
10k bitcoin pizza the atomic swap
lemonade poison
no
what was that
you guys see that yeah where's my fork
oh and of course you're gonna love this
there they are flash crash soda the
lightning network juicer what was going
on there
oh i'm sorry no no no no is he getting
funding
i'm not a fan of forks you know wait
what they're all too old for me wait are
they going to explain the rat poison
thing
oh yo
classic
thanks
yeah this is how you know it's a fanny
because all you guys are virgins you
ain't finding love on the island you
can't even find love in your [ __ ]
house
can't even find love with your goddamn
wherever the [ __ ] you go
see you around
wow i love the animation see you around
she's all glitching out and [ __ ] look at
her i'm not a fan of forks you know
who's not a fan of forks doesn't even
make sense yeah that's a crypto
reference for forks in the blockchain
yeah that's that's stupid oh okay
that one i guess watch your head maybe
the rap boys
see you around oh god or neck
[Music]
[Laughter]
well you were too busy doing wait was
the rap poison a joke or something
they have such a [ __ ] like little
culti lingo but wait it could just be
something that guys look at this she the
waiter is trying to kill him
watch this
rap poison he goes rap poison and then
the waiter gives him an ominous like
head shape
these are all like crypto memes it's
gotta be
something that is over so let me get
this straight do you know by any chance
a reference to rat poison let me get
this straight i can't think of anything
the man went to the restaurant in this
utopia and the waiters are handing out
rat poison as
appetizers warren buffet warren buffett
right-hand man called bitcoin quote rap
poison to protect casual buyers from
crypto losses oh well what does he know
what does warren buffett know about
finance
thanks andrea meal i guess they're
dunking on that okay but you're still
serving rat poison at your restaurant
okay so
maybe don't put rat poison on your
dishes because i don't want to eat rat
poison even if it's a joke
so is he gonna [ __ ] her or what while
you were too busy
i went ahead and ordered for you a 10k
pizza and a bubbly mutant serum for you
bon appetit it tastes like beef jerky
you know connie i think i'm falling in
love with this place
it's so peaceful
peaceful if it wasn't for those flying
hackers watch this
bitcoin holy smokes this is mass
adoption at its finest what's that
that's crypto land's walk of faith wow
follow the crypto stars and you'll get
to the moon
that was fun boy we are in crypto beach
and fun is the norm here
oh you invest study the best musical
this is really something
[Music]
[Music]
of my
[Music]
this is [ __ ] insane
this is so crazy brother
they all have the same face
that's the same exact face you know what
it reminds me of
that is the same character model
i actually found the website where they
bought the character models from no you
did yeah that's good
i'm not surprised i can't watch any more
of this but it's good man
i confirmed that method or that tweet to
the mental maturity dude how is that
real
maturity is just a state
what did it say
mental maturity should be more than
enough smiley face
holy [ __ ]
they they apologized for it they said
that there was a language barrier
barrier no
no that's a
dude
then you should just say 18 right right
18.
well that's crazy man
i mean the video really says it all
there's a lot more stuff but
they have a 34 page 40 34 pages
ray is concerned about the basic
infrastructure
of the island
has it pointed out the basic services
like laundry and garbage collection will
be housed on the mainland
i mean obviously this [ __ ] ain't work
ain't happening
oh and then there was a drama with
carlos because they start they use
carlos on their website and in this
video carlos shows up in this video wait
are you serious yeah yeah it's time
stamped if you want to skip to that part
right under it later i highlighted it
they still have the video up this is
their original video it's on their
website
unlisted
3000 views
so wait where's carlos cause i didn't
watch wait no this is february 20th they
must have re-uploaded it unlisted so
that they can embed it on their website
because there is an original upload that
that's been privated yeah so it is on
their website so that it seems like it's
still on where do i find crypto because
i really don't want to watch this carlos
at eight minutes and eight seconds okay
eight minutes
eight seconds
a casino oh my god
this must be a joke
hey christopher check that out i bet you
haven't seen a pinball better than this
one in your entire life
the world is not anymore like it used to
be no no no
that was a scam by the way it this thing
you see the the pinball board is called
like scam something or other
oh
look at all these details
create an account deposit your money
lock it up become rich involve family
and friends check your balance
i love these games well if you like
these games that's a scam
you might want to try carlos in new york
and ponzi connect
well i kicked bernie madoff's ass
ring ting ting ting ting ting ting talk
about the kettle calling the pot boy
[Music]
so
what happened carlos got super pissed
that they included him yeah uh carlos
tweeted out now deleted
that that's the
friend of the show carlos mattos
i guess you never know when you're
dealing with the real math toast or
someone who just copied your face onto a
new crypto scam
this is the first time i see this and
whoever's using my name brand or image
here is using it without my approval and
authorization i will definitely look
more into this and bring the student to
justice they may want to get in contact
with me with me before they hear from me
yeah about those ip laws and copyright
well he's right in that case no he is
right maybe he learned his lesson from
that whole uh episode with the uh with
the crypto bros when we had them on that
i mean he doesn't really have much of a
case though because well maybe he does i
don't know but he deleted it why i
wonder if they got in touch with them
they're like listen carlos we'll give
you a free uh
crypto bro a crony we'll give you a free
comment if your mermaid's the tweet
and then all of a sudden carlos is like
connie's are changing the world
yeah speaking of which almost done with
this but gary vee's been going on and on
about his nft restaurant in new york
in 2023 it's in seafood inspired sly
fish club will be a members only dining
club and members can be verified using
an nft so here's the thing the
restaurant is an upscale restaurant you
still have to pay for it how the [ __ ] a
restaurant gonna survive
it dude you're in new york city do you
know how many good restaurants there are
who's going to buy a crypto just to eat
at your [ __ ] mediocre restaurant
the first nft restaurant
you mean it's just a normal restaurant
fly fish
the world's first members only private
dining club
i mean this is just hutzpah this is just
it's just such by early 2023 i think
this [ __ ] will be gone by then
v friends will be totally collapsed by
the time this date comes around
he's gonna look like such an idiot
perhaps or no one will remember and
he'll just have made hundreds of
millions of dollars right
which is more likely
i just can't believe people let this guy
chill on their shows like everywhere uh
and we're announcing this morning
uh yeah it's like you said amy he used
to be all about self-help and just stuff
now he's just all about crypto and keep
making out with his dad
and thinking about killing his family
and killing him killing everyone he
loves yeah
we're launching the first nft restaurant
a membership restaurant uh we've seen
these executions uh in the city and in
other major cities but the punchline is
a very modern restaurant where the token
is the access to the membership and to
your uh table but unlike let's say a
rayos where you own the table
the table and the access is ownable by
you and transferable on the blockchain
so this is going to come out in fall
2022
uh vcr group.com how is that
a significant distinction from just a
country club or a restaurant that has a
membership fee it's
it's this yeah it's the same thing it's
just a membership fee and that's all
like
i still
i said this on the show
last week or whenever the [ __ ] it was
but like show me a use case for this
[ __ ] that is actually new because it's
just they're just reinventing the wheel
over and over again like well if this is
the best thing he can come up with
they're in big trouble at an ft
restaurant and you know he's like the
guy he's thinking about it sure he's
missed her ideas and i'm
i'm open to it i i will happily admit
i'm wrong if somebody can explain to me
you know here's something you can do
with this technology that's that's novel
that wasn't possible to do before that
actually makes sense because i hear a
lot of people propose things that are
novel but usually upon examination it
it's kind of
shaky
honestly
as of january they raised 14 million for
it hell yeah
that's not enough to open well maybe it
is actually
dude there's no way they're going to
operate there's no way dude this seems
to be as successful as trailer i'm
telling you just gonna i don't think it
will ever open frankly though i think
it's gonna be hit i'm just gonna go out
there and say that i'm gonna instagram
i'm with you love
i'm not saying i agree with it but i do
think it's going to i don't think it's
even going to happen
i don't even think it's going to open
i'm not going to see these are going to
become so much bigger soon
it's
horrible but it's going to happen
[Music]
mean level
send you dinosaurs
are they going to have a de-stress uh
chamber there like on crypto land
of course of course yeah i don't know
u.s jurisdiction it's a little what's
that
new york state i don't know
i don't see it man i don't think this
place is ever going to open
you know
we'll see so is this for v friends or a
new you have to get a new crypto
for this restaurant specifically the way
that he was pitching it on that clip it
seemed like it was a new thing but
he's integrating it with his v friends
thing or maybe he really hasn't gotten
that far and
picking it out i don't know
i'm just no i guess you just said that
they sell it they already raised much
money from it right so they must be
selling these
hold on someone said crypto land thing
is all satire the coin's name is connie
uh
that was the initial understanding a lot
of people but it that turned out to be
incorrect uh it's real it is real scam
but how can you answer what's the age of
consent and say
as long as i'm trying to say like
they're like trying to be self-aware
like making meme out of us we're like
dink doing but you don't joke about that
man well unless it's a massive troll the
people
in this space aren't oftentimes the very
self-aware yeah i'm very self-aware
well i'll be curious to see what happens
with the nft restaurant
i'd love to pay and you know knowing
garyvee is gonna be like a hundred
thousand dollars or some [ __ ] to just
get a [ __ ] seat i can't wait to go to
the nft restaurant guys
i'm seeing that starting rates for
membership were around 2.5 ethereum
or around 8 200 for unlimited
access why would you pay for this for
the
privilege of eating at a mediocre
restaurant in new york city of all
places it's just nonsense it's [ __ ]
outrageously dumb
i don't know we'll see
should we take a poll will this ever
happen i think that's the first question
we'll even open you talking about his
restaurant yeah
i mean
i mean he has the means okay whatever
i'm over it bye
oh no
emma chamberlain quits youtube
oh no
it feels so funny to talk about after
all that [ __ ]
it's just for the title guys
i like emma
uh she's she's a non-problematic queen
after two months of not posting emma
somebody's gonna
somebody she has she no emma
she has no controversy every time i feel
like i feel like you you uh you know
she's the only time you say that
she's the one she's the children
actually she murdered her sister so good
job ethan
find one bad thing about her maybe i
dare you
go ahead baby's looking
unproblematic queen emma chamberlain
uh as announced she's stepping away from
youtube and she's gonna focus on other
ventures for her mental health
she states that she may come back but it
have to be very different from what
she's doing now you know emma's really
tr transcended i have to say she's
really just
become like a model or
a how would you say socialite even
because she's just doing like
uh all this culture stuff and i'm pretty
sure she's making like bank just
working with brands and stuff in fashion
so good for her you know
here she oh here look at that somebody's
emma robbed one of our fans at gunpoint
dude that's a good job
picks or didn't happen for the past four
years not a week has gone by where i
have not thought about youtube when you
think about something from the time that
you wake up to the time that you go to
bed every single day it takes a toll on
you it takes a huge toll on you when
something is that all-consuming burnout
is completely inevitable throughout
those four years of me creating youtube
videos i've dealt with burnout time and
time again my anxiety and depression
would start to kind of creep in again
whenever that would happen i would look
at myself in the mirror and say you're
not allowed to feel burnt out because
you have the easiest job in the world
anytime i would hit burnout i would
bully myself through it basically i
wouldn't ever let myself take a break
longer than a week
and i just kept pushing through because
i was like you know what i have no
excuse and on top of that the narrative
around being a youtuber is that
you have to upload once a week
minimum or else you will become
irrelevant quicker than you can say the
abc is baby you will be done some weeks
i'm sad and some weeks i don't want
people to see my face some weeks i want
to just be silent and quiet and cozy in
my bed and i don't want to have to you
know leave
every crater's been through this you
know
if it's about burnout she'll be back
it's going to take a break you know
my solution to burnout
man it was just me and eli making like
these high production level
reaction videos it was so bad because
the problem with that stuff is every
week it's like what am i making i need
something to inspires me and it's like
bro you cannot
rush inspiration and then when sometimes
you settle and you're like listen i
gotta make a video this week this video
that i'm gonna react to isn't that great
but
i make a video and then everyone in the
comments is like not as good dude
falling off bro not as good last month
videos were ahead this one i don't know
what's happening and it's this constant
uh judgment versus strike i mean i've
been there man it's horrible the podcast
changed everything
i don't worry about what i'm making
every week and that has made all the
difference in the world where i can make
three videos three podcasts every week
show up with a smile on my face
right guys i show up with a smile on my
face yeah becoming very friendly almost
as you do yeah and then it's slowly
you're human i was saying uh
that wasn't always the case though man i
used to be [ __ ] oh it was just
struggles bro
i get the pain you know yep i get it
these glasses have changed my life and
the way that emma i don't know if you
guys are
i don't guys are familiar with the way
she makes content but she makes in the
same way she posts like a video about
something every week and that's like
impossible to to maintain
really hard
52 videos a year
that's why the most successful
youtubers are people like pewdiepie with
the longevity because it's like you can
make a video about anything you want i
mean it's still hard to find topics
don't get me wrong if you make a video
about anything you want
you make one every day you don't worry
too much about like
everything is kind of a fleeting right
it's like hey i make a video i move on
to the next day
if you can't do that you're not going to
survive in the long term in this
business and this business
not going to survive
yeah i don't know how casey went every
day for those two years that's wild
with vlogging i mean he definitely
talked about experiencing burnout but
yeah casey probably almost ruined his
whole family forever doing that
damn i mentioned a lot of stress
gotta record all day edit at night he's
a one-man show
yeah that's crazy i don't know that
would i agree that was nuts
i was really like how does he see his
kids and his wife and do anything and
then i had him on the show and he's like
oh yeah i sleep three hours a day i was
like bro you need a life
is that where you sleep so little
because you're standing casey you asked
me that the first episode of my first
episode it's gotta be true
i mean the reason i like light case in
the first place that i saw a lot of
similarities and uh oh yeah you guys you
guys basically the same person yeah yeah
pretty much
who are you more similar to me or casey
uh next question
it's casey i know the answer i don't
need you to be like me
you don't want to be like me the less
you like me the better just in general
well you don't sleep either
i mean i wake up really late
yeah i sleep that's true
this man sleeps you do sleep oh i sleep
i'm not doing another three hour a day
[ __ ] i'm on that elder ring grime
but i need sleep to perform
true
by the way speaking of elder ring i got
40 strength and now i'm able to do well
to colossal great swords damn sick amber
they're so heavy yeah wielding colossal
great swords
and i did i hit one hit is like 600
damage jesus i one hit everything
and by the way
i have to be naked because they weigh
too much
so i'm butt ass naked with two colossal
great swords
that's hilarious
it'd be what it be it do what it do
anyway shout out to emma
you'll get through it queen you couldn't
find one controversy could you
stupid [ __ ] now
exactly
she didn't talk to the dolan brothers
for
some dumb [ __ ] like
that the house there's a lot of traffic
in the chat that seemed to have had
first-hand experience
really problematic like she threw a
coffee in the face yeah
yeah there's all kinds of things yeah
the gut sword i have one
ultra long greatsword and one the other
one is the uh
the grafted greatsword
uh apparently emma was the one that gave
cam covid uh emma took a [ __ ] on their
front lawn
that can't
uh that can't be true you guys emma
punched me in the face and then stole my
wallet and spat on me wow i heard she
set a car on fire that can't be true
emma is actually vladimir putin's
personal assistant
no no no no no uh
emma just drank this person's coffee she
just reached over there no no no no no
oh here's one emma
oh well
we stand that that i believe
emma stole my cat and emma ate my cat
holy [ __ ] people want me to play elden
ring on stream i feel like it'd just be
so boring because the way i play is just
i don't feel like it's interesting to
watch the way i play i like i just don't
think that that game is necessarily that
great of a streamer game it's not it's
really slow pace for the most part
you're dying and redoing [ __ ] like a
million times in case certain cases i
mean that was the farm that was the case
with the older games too but they were
they were more linear and it like the
progress was more consistent this game
is so much about just like kind of doing
it at your own pace and exploring and
stuff and i don't know if it's
necessarily interesting for people to
watch i i think it would be so fun to
watch you play you want to see me my
naked ass dual wielding guts boy
yeah dude dude you guys it's fun to see
the frustration live too because i know
you you'd be frustrated you see there
was a a website published an article
about hassan being bad at the game
really is he really bad at it no i don't
think so but like he he got he like rage
quit at one point and like there this
website literally published an article
about it that's awesome streamer hassan
rage quits elder ring because he's
getting his ass what a loser
i have not rage quit once in fact i
think the first time i got really
frustrated was like [ __ ] was last night
when uh
just it's not even to a boss it's some
dumb you're like deep in a dungeon and
some dumb [ __ ] trash mob kills you
because they catch you in a combo that
should piss me off look
he tweeted about it bro how is this an
article click it let's see
hassan rage quits eldering after
repeatedly dying to non-boss enemy
gamerant.com what a weird thing that
would be like as somebody
who you know grew up playing video games
it just imagine having people write
articles about you sucking at it or like
getting your ass scroll down
uh
this is just click it's just clickbait
they're getting clicked there's probably
tweeted it yeah this shows up in my news
i mean [ __ ] ukraine right this is how
you get clips man
write an article ethan comments on
hassan sucking at
elden ring
[ __ ] your mom how about that
um but my build is so crazy like
i have 40
endurance and 40 strength that's where
all of my points are i have no health
i have no magic it's all just green bar
and strength
because you need like a bajillion
endurance just to be able to hold those
items right it makes sense yeah because
each of them weighs like you know over
20 pounds well that's the beauty wait so
you're level 80
is that how that works
i guess he must be yeah close to it holy
[ __ ] it must be he's getting up there
um
yeah i had to farm a lot to be able to
do it well but it's worth it bro it's so
sick so sick it's so satisfying i'm
actually seeing that um
emma plays a mage build
that's okay just stop i was trying to
add that to the problematic no it's not
problematic you're always talking [ __ ]
about mages
only when you do it because you're the
one you're the one that's supposed to be
the pro gamer
playing melee is way harder mage is easy
mode i'm not playing as a mage though
yeah you are you use magic i don't use
magic i'm do i'm my i'm using the melee
magic because guts was just a human dan
what do you understand guts didn't have
access to magic he was just a mere human
that's what i am like batman right
well that's cool man
that's really cool happy surprise how
many gamers there are in our community i
didn't know
well anyway i think it's the best game
ever
the best open world game since breath of
the wild it might even be better than
breath of the wild i just i'm i love it
it's amazing and i'm glad you guys
started playing too
you guys got the bug right we're all
yeah all in on it but you guys now
cameron and love and av you guys have so
much ahead of you because once you beat
elder ring you get to go back and play
dark souls and bloodborne which are just
as good really yeah i'm down i don't
think you're real
you don't think what
i don't think i can play these kinds of
games
ruins me
they're too emotional emotional i i rage
quit maybe 10 times a night and i like
go to bed and watch on youtube and then
you guys talk about it and i'm like
[ __ ] gonna do that that is that i
don't i think you have the souls
experience i think you after playing the
other ones so much i think i've just
transcended like i get what the game is
yeah i know what to expect i know i'm
going to [ __ ] die
this game is even easier because they've
got those marika statues or whatever
that you can spawn out like the boss
fights in the previous games you could
only spawn at campfires which were super
[ __ ] far away from the boss they
almost always have one right by the boss
too yeah that that that is a huge i'm
saying in the previous games you you got
to run a fair amount to get to the boss
yeah and then you [ __ ] die
there's like a really good chance you're
not getting those souls back yeah yeah
that's why i never got past like the
first uh level of dark souls was it dark
souls or demon souls that i have
demonstrated demon souls yeah
i would say i'd say the previous ones
it's more hardcore in that way but the
bosses are easier
in a sense
well then again i didn't really know how
to play so i don't know maybe if i go
back yeah you would you would it it
plays the same way yeah yo problematic
another problematic thing emma's done
she hasn't touched grace
touch grace she hasn't touched grace
maidenlist do you read that do you read
that as touch grass every time touch
grace no when you when you get to a new
thing it has a prompt that says touch
grade
no i know i feel like i feel like it's
subtly telling me to stop like you need
to you've been playing for six hours
straight you need to go touch grass
right now people want me to stream elden
meme
elda meme no no it's just my special
time you guys
special time
i gotta say i'm not even i'm not even um
fighting enemies right now i'm just
running around looking at stuff in the
game because it's so pretty yeah every
area is very unique it's awesome
and exploring is so fun there's always
something
interesting to do everywhere
by the way i have to my tourettes goes
crazy when i play video games so it's
not it's really awful to watch because
i'm always looking up i have this tick
where i look up in the corner so i'm
always like looking up like that it's
really bad experience for the
to watch it's quite annoying for me too
but sure even more for you
so anyway queen eli or queen emma
shout outs
uh to the queen
or whatever she'll be back like you said
she gets good views man just doing like
little vlogs pretty crazy she's popular
yeah good for her
you know
but here's the big news
jeffree star reunites with shane dotson
baby
the boys are back in town
jeffree star reunited with shane dawson
after not being seen in years at his
skin care launch party
hollywood reporter asked jeffree and
starr
questions about being canceled exciting
exciting guys this is huge news look at
this
jeffree star in that
he's in that uh
[Music]
those shoulders are giving me who's the
the the
evil queen in snow white
is it is she just called the the evil i
don't know i don't know i don't know i'm
not i'm not enough of
no maleficent was from sleeping beauty
queens
i just contradicted i said i'm not a
disney head but i do know that
right or
melissa sleep whatever the fair mirror
mirror on the wall who's the fairest of
them all yeah i don't i know what you're
talking about jeffree star estimate that
they're like not you [ __ ]
oh the wicked queen from the
right evil queen her name is literally
evil queen okay evil queen
giving me evil queen from snow white
also known as the wicked queen
wow a lot of
background
jesus there's a lot of background
but we get it
runs deep the wicked queen was
re-imagined into the marvel universe
somebody said her name is emma
no stop it
how dare you
[Music]
how is it seeing shane
dude looks like he's wearing a green
screen outfit
so shane's here tonight right i noticed
that he leaves the house and you're
about to see him we're actually real
best friends even through all the drama
and craziness we always have each
other's back that's not what trisha told
me
that's a reliable source
well she was friends with all of them
no comment further than that
really he's here to support and he
hasn't left the house in two years did
you guys have a falling out before you
never did yeah you never did i think
what i heard giving me ruby ross
ruby ross was awesome though ruby rod
yeah
ruby rod
such a player dude
love fifth element we'll assume that
because there was so much chaos yeah but
we're perfect yeah do you think that you
would ever be back friends with anyone
that you've had falling outs with if you
ever want to apologize let me know
really okay okay okay all right how have
you guys been
you know what
really good
i'm doing good good yeah how are you
doing mentally
are you mentally doing okay how was the
move how do you make a joke um
no jokes uh yeah i'm doing really good
you're doing well haven't see i don't
think i've ever seen you and jeffrey
together in the same spot ever so that
we are the same person no i'm saying i
haven't seen you
you together how was it how was it
you know
you would never fit in that dress shane
you're not the same person
he made that joke to be fair just saying
he's still he wait he said made that
joke didn't he say in a fat suit or
something we're the same person and he
did yeah
i don't think i've ever seen you and
jeffrey together in the same spot ever
so now
no i'm saying i haven't seen you okay
and a fat suit yeah very just saying
very good
just saying together how was it how was
it
you know seeing jeffrey
um
great i don't know everything is very
weird right now because yeah i guess i
haven't
left the house oh yeah i leave the house
now but to go to like target so are you
are you gonna come back are you gonna
start making stuff again i mean is is
there
that's what i'm i mean he already did he
is making stuff i mean can you move on
after being cancelled or like how does
that work
uh yeah i don't know i guess yeah i hope
so i don't know i like making stuff and
so are you on tick tock no no are you
are you doing anything social media
related or youtube related or anything
yeah i'm gonna start posting more videos
randomly randomly
do you get when you post do you get are
like good comments or do people hate on
you or like um i don't i i read a little
bit
and then he'll tell me he'll say they're
nice so then i'll look and i'll reply
but yeah people okay i feel like i don't
know i'm in a good place i'm happy and
people are you know it is what it is and
i'm happy okay well that's good yeah
just are you friends with james charles
i really thought you're gonna say jamie
lynn and i was jamie wait no no don't
dodge the question i'm just curious i'm
not trying to get canceled again
i don't know i'm not a part of that you
don't know
because james like he got cancelled too
and i talked to him and he kind of
bounced back at this point
don't do that
nobody been canceled for like what you
guys been counseled for i said some
naughty words
y'all tried to [ __ ] some kids
jesus
changes me
right he didn't i was just i was just
james is a different story yeah james
did do that
i was thinking like you know now that
james has been canceled you all have
probably a lot more in common to talk
about you know maybe they're closer than
ever
wow sister snapped the fact that james
charles has a career and is still
posting is truly an everyday
baffle it's just it's incredible
it's gross
oh man
right
back in there you know you can always
block comments and or just leave them
turned off okay
do you think he should start posting
again or what do you think he is he just
came back you did okay so i'm behind on
this randomly randomly randomly what did
you do with your old videos do you put
them on private do you think i asked a
lot of questions man
walk away bro i don't know why you stand
like yeah go have dinner or something i
don't know what the [ __ ] this is like
brigading him like i think it's planned
yeah and they have something
um i want to do this you guys the
reporter's been to shane's house before
oh really yeah
you you want to uh have the paparazzi
come up and this guy and acosta like
this well i'm pretty sure
yeah you can just reach out you keep
saying we got to go to the saddle ranch
and have this guy meet us yeah you could
just and i think you could just reach
out to them and be
like i think often times that is what
can we stage a fight or something
i don't think you even have to do that i
think you can literally dm them and be
like i'm going to be at this restaurant
tonight no we d m them have them come up
on stage a fight or something oh and
then i feel like if we damn them they
may leak the information to some people
um who was gonna show up for us what
would they look like there's a few
people
talking about it on the show you think
that they would tell like someone like
oh ethan's gonna be here if you want to
meet him i got a hot tip
who's like who like facebook
going to show up phase blank jeff
already follows our every move so
who do you think who do you think would
show up to fight me or something who
wouldn't show up
no i'm kidding i don't know
we have facebook we burn a few bridges
here and there
yeah [ __ ]
i think emma chamberlain might show up
that's true
my bridge is intact with emma queen
unproblematic
i'd fight chain shane's one person i'd
fight i'm not a fighter i don't have
physical prowess but i feel like i could
[ __ ] up shane
i think he's just equally
more wussy than me
yes did you did youtube demonetize your
account
[Music]
yeah
but i don't i'm listen and i'm not
i know you so i don't want to be one of
those people also nobody cares but also
i am really happy
i think they they probably demonetize
them for like two weeks and brought it
back that's what they usually do
so shane and jeffrey are launching
makeup
and james charles is making videos i
love that though you can't be like yo
we've all been canceled y'all come on
now
something like i i tweeted out a weird
meme
like well
as we always say i mean
with few exceptions these cancellations
so to speak
i mean i'm going to his channel right
now
his last video two weeks ago 3.2 million
views i mean the guy like
what does it really mean
what do you what does it mean to be
canceled when you're still putting out
content that's getting dude the one
before that four million views james
charles literally admit to being a
predator he said and and and
to paraphrase i am a predator right and
he's still posting and getting millions
of five days ago one point one i mean
and his his is down a lot more than
shane's but again like you were just
saying i mean
it's like
what james did is
okay it's just really funny
crypto
[Laughter]
[Applause]
this [ __ ] guy
i'm not physically attracted to older
guys
and that's what he's admitting on a
public podcast my dudes
those sound bites man
have a seat over here
james it's still so crazy that exists
james charles i have the uh dms here
once you have a seat listen up here
it says
it says i'm not 18 and you say well
that's okay that's a good a this is i'm
15. that's a good age you said
did you bring condoms that's a good age
to be did you bring condoms
rollo tony browntown check yourself
right at the door
rollo tony you guys remember
yes we remember
and
all of us in this office have not been
able to get that song out of our head
for the last like three days it's like
literally every single one of us and we
all hate it but we can't stop i've been
singing it i'm sorry dan not to
interrupt but i [ __ ] love it but yes
i can't get it out of my head well i
think it's a great little tune but i
hate that i can't stop singing it wait
cam posted this damn i see you guys at
1am shoots ice
i got a [ __ ] dagger that shoots ice
it's sick wait
i don't even remember it was hard to
find it was in some weird secret place
no it doesn't even cost magic you just
swing it and it shoots up ice that's i
need that for my that sounds a lot like
magic
it doesn't use magic does it shoot
something and guess what
i don't use it i was just projectiles
i've never killed one monster with the
dam before you start getting up getting
all intense i have never used it
i was only showing well i would use that
because that's yeah
that's your stick i don't give a [ __ ]
sick
whatever anyway rolo tony browntown
check yourself right at the door
you know you want some rollo's you know
you gotta give me some more
of those rolos
yeah so rolo tony browntown he was the
guy that um
the fresh and fit guys are trying to
bring on to debate yeah and then he
starts beefing with me talking about
rolo is saying that i don't want to
debate him because i'm scared
robo claims to hardly know who ethan is
and says the real reason he doesn't want
to bait is because he would wipe the
floor with him i don't [ __ ] want to
debate you because i don't care i don't
know who you are
and
yeah why is he making
everyone who has beef with you says that
at first i i roughly know who he is
what's his name
oh yeah what's his name ethan they can't
pronounce your name for some reason yeah
ethan klein
why do they do that i don't i don't know
i think because he has a smaller uh
platform maybe he feels intimidated i
don't know what the hell it is
but why do they gotta act like they
don't know who i am
so here he is here's rolo tony browntown
who in this video reveals he's 52 years
old and the dude has a chin strap bro
and it's gray
and a ponytail stop
this is the red pill godfather
i uh
this is one of the first times of me
seen a picture of him because some of
the pictures on lineup short hair he
looks like he could be in like a death
metal band or something yeah definitely
like lamb of god or like one of those
got that bag well that's cool i guess
but when you learn out he's a pickup
coach does that is that cool i just he
doesn't he doesn't look like a pickup
coach type guy he's 52 man you're
supposed to
this is not an old man's game red pill
is not an old man's game
i mean it should be no man's game let's
be fair
so here is rolo tony browntown who
invited himself on our show
to the point was like no i don't want to
talk to him that's stupid here he is
responding to me not wanting to talk to
his dumb ass
who gets 50 000 views per video i don't
care about it he's not on my radar
nobody cares about you rolo davos sent
me this the other day and um i am only
peripherally aware of
a guy you invited yourself on my show
instead of coconuts and barbados
which he has some choice words yeah he's
called coconuts and dumb which is what
we suspected
ethan uh what the hell's the name even
klein
oh my god it's the exact same [ __ ]
energy it was uh was it crowder that did
it crowder there's been a few people but
yeah crowder did it ethan
ethan ethan ethan what's his name
kaleen you clean italian colleen
possibly doesn't know who i am
which is fine he invited himself on my
show though he knows damn well who i am
right it's fine to not know who we are
and most people don't most people in
this world don't know who we are so
that's that's perfectly fine but like
you said he he inserted himself into
this conversation yeah
rolo
oh he does have a guitar in the backside
yeah
and that is definitely a metal guitar
yeah and they have chin strap
the grey chin strap and i'm just noting
this
noticing this it looks like he's wearing
a lambo god shirt not to [ __ ] on the
band but
oh my god he might be so is that about
is that a bad one i don't know no i'm
just saying he looks the part
that's all i'm saying it's making an
observation did you really not
well you can't see it but that's right
just noticing this holy [ __ ] but what is
the significance of that
no it's just he nailed it's just that he
nailed his whole vibe like yeah if you
got it just just one look at him can i
ask you do you think he's bald with a
pony because i always thought that look
was interesting he's wearing a hat so i
mean
he might have he might be bald with a
pony which is a killer look in my
opinion yeah i mean he could have might
have a keeper can you cut a picture of
rolo tony browntown uh
male pattern baldness
wait what what is this
googling
[Laughter]
rolo tomasi rolo
tomasze hey cam's got some let's check
that hairline bro the real reason why
you hate me
is because my [ __ ] hairline is insane
dude
what is this you sent me uh is this
that's not him is it
i know i think that is that is him yeah
the reason cam sent that because that's
one of the only photos of him without a
hat
but he doesn't have a ponytail on this
one so this must be like
ancient wait what or new or what oh look
at he looks old as [ __ ] in this
but then he how much time would he have
to grow a whole ponytail
maybe his hair grows faster
that'll take what how long does it take
to grow a whole ponytail zach a few
years i mean yeah like that depends on
the person yeah taking you better been
around this hairline looks okay i'm not
gonna hate his hairline looks pretty
good all those red pills man it's
hairdresser oh my god stefan molinax
yeah chad really tells you everything
you need to know isn't it
check the discord he says
check the discord
holy [ __ ] bro oh wow wow that's the red
pill god that wants to come on our show
that man is walking death he's [ __ ]
voltory
this guy's in hospice care man i feel
like every photo of him he looks wildly
different what is this bro
he kind of looks like glenn danzig a
little bit
goth brock bratzo
he's giving me bronzo with the guru [ __ ]
hmm
yo he looks like the the ice king
from lord from [ __ ] game of thrones
he's so pale
people saying he might
and old
his hair might be fake
no no you don't think so how does he
have long hair he's got short hair he's
got a ponytail
the ponytail's connected to the back of
his hat you can't tell because of the
hat something doesn't make sense here
yeah
but all that being said good hairline
actually
good hairline it is a good hairline good
hairline for somebody in their 50s
damn please
let's watch rollo tony browntown
uh talk about me how does he he looks so
different
in every picture i feel like everything
i'm seeing of him i feel like it's a
different guy it is very strange
are you even real i i didn't recognize
him like it's it's weird
okay let's watch
ethan wait wait here he goes
say my hi ethan how are you
my name is rola tamassi
don't care wait wait here how he clicks
his
nonstop
my name is brother i didn't ask for you
you went you asked to come on my show i
don't need an introduction i don't want
an introduction i'm gonna watch it
though
and uh
apparently did you stay here i am not a
troll you're not a troll i'm not troll i
want you guys to see things through the
lens of prophecy okay well thank you
very much uh what
wait here you go i think he's just
bouncing off the chat
she's not a christian
there you go
all right good drops
so i want to introduce you to this guy
uh now
if you are familiar with h3 uh the h3
podcast it's big he just called me h3 he
knows who i am
ethan klein say my name
it's certainly bigger than him i think
he's got more subs than tim poole so
he's definitely not a farm league
podcast
i no idea that myron was temple is his
idea of the biggest name in the space by
the way
definitely bigger than tim pool even
talking about this guy i'm only like i
said i'm only peripherally aware of the
dude because i think he was talking [ __ ]
about michaela peterson at some point
maybe somebody
might have come up in my
my twitter feed i
i don't know who the dude honestly i
have no clue who this guy was until like
myron made a big deal out of him and
said hey you want to go on this guy's
podcast and he really wanted me to go
with him
and it's in los angeles so it's not too
far from where i'm at i mean probably be
there and like you know it was a quick
flight down
from reno
and
reno and i'm like oh sure i would love
to do that i think i'd i meant you
weren't invited
to not to defend this guy
but he just gets a message from the
[ __ ] fit guy like come do like
he's like okay yeah sure i'll do that
sure you know sure it's more on the
fresh and fit guys being [ __ ] idiots
yeah they weren't yeah totally mentioned
something about it um
on my
last show in my last interview on fresh
and fit which was back in actually
beginning this month
um
and i said it will be a great day when
myron and myself can actually go on the
same podcast and and sort of go
head-to-head with whoever right because
i mentioned that
because i'm rolo because i'm a white guy
i can only go certain places and because
myron is myron and he's a red pill guy
he's in the black manosphere he's going
to get calls from people that i'm not
going to get
and vice versa i should say so it's not
just it's not a race thing it's just you
know those are our spheres that's where
we run
mike rasheed is not going to call rolo
tomasi but myron gaines is going to go
on his show and pretty much talk about
the same thing i would have talked about
anything so that's fine
then you know myron fresh are going to
get the call to go on flagrant they're
going to get the call to go on
tim poole
i think we're still waiting on that
rogan phone call
that'll be the day man
when red pill rollo tony goes on joe
rogan then we'll know it's all is truly
lost
um
and so there's places that i'm like for
instance i went on patrick bed david i
went on adam sosnick and so did myron
and fresh right we weren't there
together but we were there you know
individually
and i'm always happy to cross-pollinate
i'm always happy to say hey here's a
here's a network here's a guy talk to
this dude i brought adam sosnick into
the studio
i don't know on the tuesday i did the
patrick bet david show just because it
happened to be convenient and he lives
in brickell
not brickell brickell
and and it worked out and and they hit
it off and not as i knew they would and
then they a week later they went on
adam's show and that was fantastic i
thought it was a really great show in
fact i thought it was one of the best
interview
oh you're so boring
i know how collaborations work yeah
there's some he's like listen sometimes
i go on other people's show and
sometimes they come on my show and we
club we close we cross collaborate
and sometimes i go on the show and it's
good
sometimes i go on the show and it's
pretty good sometimes it's really good
sometimes it's really really good yeah
sometimes they come on my show and
that's good too
i go it
good we get it bro tighten it up a
little bit there's a user the doc has uh
some time stamps okay i thought it was
just one thing no no no no okay jesus
christ he calls me a fat obnoxious piece
of [ __ ] i love it
that's my favorite bro
did i look big in that photo what is
happening with my body dude
built like a donut roll
that's the shirt is doing something
weird why look so top heavy
looks like i guess you're pumping out
your chest i look like i got some ds
though
looking like meatloaf and fight club
[ __ ] yeah totally rip to the goat
[Laughter]
oh i forgot that was meatloaf damn yeah
now i get it i get his bran right i get
why he's doing what he's doing
he's just sort of this fat obnoxious
you know piece of [ __ ] that yeah i i
know a lot of these guys there's a lot
of dudes i get it bro you know that
vertical the fat
protocol i've seen it a million times
yeah i got it begged fat obnoxious
pieces of [ __ ] sounds like a really
successful formula yeah
i get it what's that
is that jordan peterson on his desk yes
it is
we that good baby we got busts of
peterson so here's your hero now do you
own his bust
i bust on that bust i love him so much
can you say the same
full tributes
[Laughter]
please no i should do that and send them
a picture
i'm gonna come
there's a lot of dudes that sort of
fumble into their their niche and i get
the feeling that that's where
that's where ethan is at now fumbled
into my niche what does that mean bro
i've been doing this for over 10 years
indeed
and you're decent at it you know well
thank you
you know it's a work in progress though
uh i think so uh would you say uh wait
wait wait let me back up a little bit
because infamous rifle asked me you said
isn't he the dude that said he was like
in better shape than
than uh yeah that's exactly what i said
you brain rot
joe rogan yeah well i can i can
guarantee you this if i had opposed if i
at 53 here we go
fat man bad
middle it [ __ ] old ass red pillar
good
is that a pose down with ethan i can
guarantee you i am in better shape than
you are good for i mean great probably
nobody said yeah yeah i don't know i
have no problem conceding that and i
never did
that
strong man good
fat man bad or ethan
um but
who the [ __ ] am i to this guy like where
the [ __ ] did this come from you're
nobody that's the point they don't know
where you entered this conversation
but when people talk about me i watch
you know me i'm petty as [ __ ] yeah i
always take the bait petty king always
petty king climb
no idea who this dude even was
until then now here's the other thing oh
wait should i go to another time stamp
what are you afraid of
ian he called out ian he calls him calls
out again
what oh he calls me ian yes he calls you
what are you afraid of ian i'll be happy
to yeah yeah i'd debate you i won't i
won't bite right
like what what so if it's whether it's
fresh or it's not you know here i love
that the conclusion is that i'm afraid
to abate him that nobody cares i want
people to watch my show and be
interested
i'm having on today as a guest
joe the hot dog salesman
aka someone nobody's ever heard of to
debate me probably joe the hotdog
salesman got more interesting stories
than
rolo tony
here's the reason i want to explain to
you why
this dude is you know actually before i
do that i have to show you this this is
really good now i'm going to put this on
there real fast just so people know what
the here's here's your frame of
reference in all of this now this was
from
so
they've been sending our dms to rollo
tony apparently
this is
actually podcast right again
this whole like theater about not
knowing who you are like and he's like i
think i saw him
making fun of michaela peterson that's
what started this whole thing we were
talking about the fresh and fit podcast
that she was on
and you
made fun of it it's he's fully aware of
all of these i don't i don't there's no
reason to pretend like you're you're
just learning about this in real time
you have the conversation like i guess
it's just to make me seem irrelevant or
something even though he's he's begging
to come on the show dude this guy
donated she said rolo needs to roll on
out of here pronto
got him [ __ ]
good by the way did he really post a
video simping for the twinders the
tinder swindler tinder swindler is
swindling women
i i mean i'd have to watch it to know i
do know that he's selling red pill lion
nfts
and
is getting
huge traction on that 13
000 views yeah so yeah dude
i mean do you want to know why i don't
want to debate you i want to talk to
fresh and fit that's the interesting
conversation okay
i don't want to talk to random red
pillars i don't
i don't care if you're the godfather of
the red pill the god the god of red pill
i don't care if you are
you know
like kind of good at guitar
it really just doesn't interest me
i don't care if you've made out with a
thousand girls bro
just don't care
don't care is rolo married
help dude i don't know look it up but i
guarantee you he's alone he is forever
alone
that's what the red pill says
[ __ ] [ __ ] die alone that's their
mantra i mean maybe maybe not that man
is single or not as the day is long
looks like he is married and how's it
going red pill and have a daughter
married
okay well i stand corrected
i thought their mantra was [ __ ] [ __ ]
die die by yourself
uh i don't think that that's their
mantra
really [ __ ] [ __ ] die by yourself yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] die alone
i'm
i'm not because i know they ain't
building healthy relationships with that
red pill yeah
so he's married and has daughters
according to a random google search
your way into a family there you go
he said you don't marry a woman you
marry all the men what what the [ __ ]
does this mean he literally tweeted this
out
you don't marry a woman you marry all
the men she had before it was your turn
to be the one
you loser
you really are so insecure and pathetic
that's a new york times article though
well but he tweeted it with that caption
i see
dude how insecure can you be
you can't handle that your girl had sex
with other dudes because you know you're
so pathetic and small compared to them
god forbid she had other lovers in her
life
even though your whole life is built
around just trying to have sex with
women as objects
pathetic
just have some confidence man you you
the women the men that she slept with
before you have no relevance on your
relationship i mean other than you know
the the formations maybe affected her
her personality and stuff the experience
she's been through but this is like such
a pathetic isis-style tank
puritanical
this is the most beta take
you don't marry a woman you marry all
the men she had before what do you mean
you suck in their dicks you bringing
them in and doing a [ __ ] what are you
doing bro you're marrying all the men
she had before it was your turn
are you into that what are you talking
about it's like you're in the corner
jerking off and they're all [ __ ] all
over your girl no dude
she's allowed to have sex and be
sexually free just like you
yeah that's why
at the root of all red pills it's it's
it's women hating
it's deep insecurity and it's women
hating
because they don't get to be independent
but you do
they don't get to live fulfilled lives
but you do
they don't get to have sexual partners
without being judged but you do
why
here's oh he expanded this is exactly
what i mean when i talk about women
being alpha widows
it also confirmation of why women with
higher end count damn this guy's like i
don't even know i don't even know what
the [ __ ] he's using lingo that's like
high level
die alone [ __ ]
uh it's also confirmation of why women
with higher end counts statistically
have more difficulty in developing
strong emotional attachments for the
long-term mates and experience higher
rates of divorce what
of course this guy has daughters by the
way that's like the perfect god's curse
on him for being who he is
this is what happens when a woman's
rationalization hamster gets a column in
the new york times
can you just speak english bro
he has like the pseudo science talk that
makes him seem like what he's talking
about isn't just
pure women hating trash
rollo tony brown town get yourself right
at the door
did you want an experienced woman who's
like been around
experience things and when she meets you
and she falls in love with you and she
chooses you then you know it's real you
want a woman who's never experiencing
anything like what kind of weird
pathetic insecure
beta [ __ ] is that better
this is sad anyway let's listen
i have in the daca i'm talking about
coconuts and barbados
should i skip forward i want to see him
read this comment who cares we already
looked at these yeah i mean
let me watch it a little bit of
correspondence since they already posted
this by the way i didn't post this this
was already on their their podcast the
most recent podcast of h3 they put this
up there so i'm not selling anybody out
they've already done this it's already
been put out okay so how do we know how
do we know he won't bring someone else
else on like crowder you're really that
worried about stephen craig
that was what your dude said
that's what his dude said
he's goofing on his own homie right now
yeah i thought i misunderstood that i
don't dude you're so stupid you're
making fun of your friend he's the one
that told us that
router we don't i don't even know i
don't have any contact with stephen
crowder he doesn't even know much man
you're pretty dumb
like
the dm was sent by your friend
and he's the one that was being a little
baby about it
how he he said how do i know you won't
break someone like you do with crowder
and i love how his home he's like wow
this guy's a [ __ ] i was like yeah i
agree
it's awesome
these guys are dumb dude there's just
stupid bro it's awesome the chat said he
accidentally left friendly fire on
right exactly
yo i might be fat but i'm not this dumb
kim starts watching right now what do
you mean can you can
he tweeted uh something but he is
yeah
keemstar is always wait what does this
meme mean he's saying that he look old
but i don't think he realizes that he
can't well dude he like edited this
photo by the way
he made me look all ghoulish
he's watching us right now making memes
keemstar you're my biggest fan just
admit it you start
take off the hat dude
stop coloring your beard stop calling
your beard also that has like beauty
filter on look how polished his pores
are i don't care though
why are you so cute when you talk [ __ ]
why did you make me
i don't look like that
why did you do that
seems a bit insecure he's very insecure
i mean he's like you said seven days
from 40 he's lashing out i look young
and beautiful
yeah take the hat off stop dying the
beard don't beauty filter
i don't care though what how old i look
like i don't because i have a family
i'm married
you know i'm not looking to pick up the
18 year olds on tinder it's fine
if you have insecurity about how you
look why do you need to compare yourself
to me it's between you
and the 17 year old who's turning 18 in
two days that you got your eye on
you got to look younger for them not me
bro
that being said
you have the hairline of a guy
yeah i mean
i mean now that guy don't look that
young
on the right there
that's updated
that's updated
hold on but you gotta you gotta edit his
skin to make look he just came out of a
tomb or some [ __ ] chad is saying this is
bully bait
he's trying to bait us you think he's
bully baiting me you are bullying me
he bullied me he called me oh you saw
that
all right let's get off what's all that
abe did that
now he's comparing me to hitler
what did he do to my skin that's so
crazy sharpening filter it looks like oh
yeah yeah
i think i look fine i'll be honest even
with that crazy ass filter i'm happy
with the way i look keemstar
it's okay
ethanol all right kisser always uses
that angle too from the side like that
like the specific angle that he knows
dude you're obviously so insecure about
your age just do you deal with your [ __ ]
i don't care at least he's getting out
from the bathroom pics i mean that's a
step forward he's out of the bathroom
yeah that's progress for a four-year-old
maybe he's trying to get ahead of the
fact that he's about to turn 40 and he
thinks i think you're right yeah he's
trying to meme it now
i might be turning i might be 40 and
still making drama videos but at least i
don't look as bad as this guy right
okay
yeah if you google keemstar you you get
a lot of pictures from the side like
just like that it's very funny oh that's
real interesting he always hitting from
the same angle yeah
can you put an album that i can click
through
he's like that girl you've seen those
videos where the girls on instagram take
like the same exact picture and they
just there's like a slideshow where
their face like doesn't move but the
setting changes that's him
he has a good side
i can't get over this picture man he
really being flirty in it
he really flirty in this
you know
bomb
that's awesome dude
well shout out to [ __ ]
hello keemstar
happy birthday by the way and happy soon
to be for you
to another 20 years of reporting on
dixie emilia
not that i do anything different but
is do i do is what we do different
absolutely it is good because you're not
like losing your [ __ ] like dixie demilio
actually keem hit me with that uh i
don't know your name i mean i'm
definitely less relevant than you but he
knows who you are he definitely but he
finally said my name is like star first
he said my name like three times and
he's like or star [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ]
his name is yeah he knows who you are
my boy all right let's go back to rollo
yo dude he's like covered in ice that's
crazy
does he have ac or what in his room
that one's a totally unedited photo
crazy dude you look old as hell in that
you're like santa claus
all right let's watch tilt roller tony
keep the memes coming kim's other great
entertaining
my name man
hd podcast freshman fit how do you know
we won't bring someone like a crowd from
the crowder um he read it twice remember
his friend said that
it's so good it's so good is he afraid
of i never promised crowder i wouldn't
i'll tell him i tell him i am promising
uh you guys have been critical of the
red pill and fresh and fit slash rollo
are the biggest creators in the space
well at least thank you for
acknowledging that it will uh be a great
discussion and we'll get a lot of views
instantly i think that's the other side
of the conversation he says no it won't
it'll get a lot of views instantly viral
no it won't
okay we'll think on it okay no problem
i'll pass this on to myron and fresh
tomorrow then he comes out ethan wanted
me to say that he's doing a hard pass on
rolo why
but why because nobody [ __ ] cares
uh so just let us know if you're up for
fresh and fit versus ethan and hassan so
so that pretty much confirms everything
that they were just talking about a
minute ago
and my only question is
what are you afraid of
why
i'll be happy to i should i'll fly down
there on my own
of course you will of course you will
fly down here
you want the exposure
i don't care i'm not having
whatever show me keemstar sideshot
keemstar
super confident always hitting them from
that left side baby
always from the left side oh that one's
from the right side
take that one out of there
i think it's flipped
always from the left side
always looking fresh from the left side
only with a hat on
is that his real hairline
no
what the hell
yeah
wait let me see that one with him with
hair
it doesn't do much for him does it
because it does a little bit
it does help yeah it helps
that was just the topic images on google
there's more
where are you at la san diego forget
where he is
he said southern california i don't know
exactly where this guy literally invited
himself on the show and then when we
said no he's like what are you scared of
it's okay i'm from southern california
i'll be happy to go down [ __ ] i'll drive
down there
i'm sure you will dude catalina while
i'm out there whatever you need man
nothing a bike
whatever i'll walk if i need to might
take a nap let me know you know what if
you walk here then we can talk on your
show yeah
it's a weekend of it
what are you afraid of no you know what
you're afraid of is because they want
fresh and fit on there because they know
fresh is not like
fresh is not rolled tomas i love you
fresh i really do
dude that's just beautiful isn't it
because the reason they don't want me is
because fresh is [ __ ]
brain dead
the man is incapable of holding a
conversation he said this about his own
friend
and he called the other guy
a [ __ ] for being afraid of crowder
unintentionally so you didn't respect
them
i do
but fresh is not me
and i love fresh you know that i talked
about
coconuts and barbados
saw my my most recent clips channel i
talk about like how fresh talked about
like owning a woman's soul
and i made a a specific point to talk
about that when i was on my last uh okay
now he's going off on some weird red
pill [ __ ] but like
i love that he calls one of them
irredeemably dumb and the other one a
giant wuss for being scared of crowder
oh my god here's the real meme yeah chad
ethan verse goofy odd game
[Music]
how'd you do that chad ethan you look
like brad pitt maybe you ran it through
that's what i was thinking four times in
a row
i i did
merge it with brad pitt actually oh
really oh yeah
my hair looks hella good dude
it kind of looked like um what's his
name off the charts and in your heart
mark mcgrath
you said you went from looking like bob
from fight club well now you look like
tyler durden yeah
love that
and there's one more oh he imitates me
which is a quick little goof oh no
a rollo tony brown town
check
and that's why guys like ethan get all
bent out of shape and they try to yuck
it up
[Music]
the reason you want to like you know be
[ __ ] middle school [ __ ] is
because you know i'd [ __ ] wipe the
floor with you
you know i would [ __ ] like you know
destroy you when it comes to like any
kind of and even myron will probably i
don't even have to be there really myro
probably right
yeah coconuts and barbados that's not
included yeah no picking coconut some
barbados
i mean part of the reason i even wanted
to have those guys on is because i
wanted to talk to coconut and barbados
right because i found it so interesting
that that guy was had a podcast
you know
but the fact is that you still want
fresh on there because the odds are the
fresh is going to say own your soul and
that's going to be the clip that you
throw out on your soul i didn't know
what you're saying dude
apparently he said something dumb
yeah but we don't want that we want the
coconuts and barbados yeah i don't care
about owning your soul i know you guys
are weirdos about women that's not a
surprise
that's why that's the new marketing plan
somebody watches
you know you want to know why shorts are
more you know
you want to go and look at like uh rich
cooper's shorts are great man you're
going to look at his short clips cause
he just saw he's just hot he's just off
yeah he's talking about how people want
to watch his shorts and that's what you
want out of uh coconuts barbados can you
look up some roller tony quotes i bet he
got some real psycho [ __ ] out there
let's find some bangers let me find like
his great moments
we've been going for a while we're gonna
do a segment of our biggest fears
yeah we've probably already been going
two hours eh oh well over uh two and a
half
yeah we could save that for another time
i i knew this this episode was stacked
anyway yeah that says rollo tony creeps
her out guys me too sweetheart
me too
what the [ __ ] apparently uh kanye west
buries pete davidson in new music video
i'll bet he does
that's just a little bit much don't you
think
pull up this steph noodles post that you
just posted an hour ago about it
uh well if it's a music video we won't
we'll get claimed if we no i just want
to see we can mute it says women will
cry a river about wanting mr dependable
and then go off to [ __ ] mr exciting
maybe you just
well there's a lot to unpack there dude
but i would say the problem probably
lies with you
you cannot blame the world for ex if you
blame the world for everything you'll
never change and you'll just be a shitty
person
sorry rollo somehow you become 52 years
old and still haven't learned anything
about life
bro this is getting crazy kanye west
is this like i'm not sure that you can
threaten to kill someone even in a music
video
i mean morally no but uh let's not show
this
get it get it out of here
that's weird
i don't like him i don't know if i've
ever mentioned that on the show before
you know there's like rap beefs like you
know biggie and two pack
they go at each other two packs
jakar
but in this case pete's just minding his
business
and kanye's saying i'm gonna kill you
that can't be that that that
that's a bit much
everyone lived happily ever after except
skeet
you know who
yeah i think they need a restraining
order in fact i don't even think this
video should be allowed online
we needed to start treating kanye like
russia we need like an embargo on this
guy
he's dangerous
we need to phrase his ass he does within
the realm of a music video is you know
it's art it's free speech
i don't think he can actually get in
trouble i don't think so if you're
threatening to kill someone
i don't think they think there's a pre
yeah i mean i don't like it either but i
don't does this guy do sunday service
every sunday and then he's going and
threatening to kill people yeah he's a
giant hypocrite of course
jesus said i hate pete davidson let's
bury him
okay well
i guess we're just gonna talk about this
stuff
on friday there's lots of other good
stuff here
yeah let's save it
i've been going biggest fears i do want
to talk about that ukraine stuff there's
some good stuff
here alone
bober
ryan cavanaugh video oh i do want to
watch this always
what's this that's harley weinstein
no neither oh this is the girl this is
the fan submitted video this is the fan
this girl's been running ads on our
channel right yes that's so crazy
yo this girl has been running ads on our
channel promoting her
her ryan or harvey video so i'm gonna
watch it
i'm gonna watch it it's 4 20.
excellent david david dobrik inspired
yeah
so here we go let's do it her name is uh
love
k-ray
the public is confused does ryan look
like harvey weinstein this is a parody
of you inspired by kavanaugh vs ethan
klein
all right so here you go
love k-ray nobody's ever run ads on our
channel trying to promote a clip so she
kind of transcended
i think crowder did
but not for her crowder was running ads
on her channel i believe so wasn't he
what a troll they were paying me yeah i
remember though
what ads was he ranked just to promote
his channel this is videos yeah cause
after we uh
we got him really what a weird thing to
do
like our audience isn't gonna go watch
him first of all you don't have to think
about it second one why is he paying me
money i think as far as ego he's like oh
i didn't get got i'm getting them i'm
putting ads on their video realizing
that he's just not realizing that he's
just wasting money i'm totally fine with
him putting ads on my video
man i have no problem with that i mean
i'm just happy to get paid
i'm so confused do you know if that's
harvey weinstein or if that's harvey
weinstein
no neither okay they look similar though
right it's the same a little yeah yeah
yeah oh interesting a little yeah
they look similar though right
she's right especially when you put
their faces together like that it's
crazy
got that trailer swag that's impressive
flip it upside down i want one of those
after weeks of running around new york
city plastering flyers and stickers on
every poll i could get my hands on the
public is still confused is ryan
cavanaugh and harvey weinstein the same
person
dude that i actually that is really
compelling
seeing their faces together like that
side by side it's the same person it's
crazy they just look strangely similar
they are indeed different people do you
know that's harvey weinstein or that
party lion king um may i ask what
organization you're with
it's her project i have to print
something at michaels oh okay no she's
with uh does ryan kavanagh look like
harvey weinstein.com
that's a fair question why are you
asking me this do you know which one's
which yeah the dude on the right the
right sorry one two okay don't they look
kind of similar or not
yeah a little bit yeah
thank you do you think they look alike i
guess somewhat that's always safe for
him to look like i know i know are you
familiar with ryan cavanaugh but no he's
been arrested for multiple duis and
still driving
yeah i love this video
she's so funny this is so freaking good
well she's educating the public it's
important yeah
all right so kind of
a little bit from the eyes eyes up
that's what we hear the eyes do you know
if that's harvey weinstein or if that's
harvey weinstein
that one's hard though they kind of look
similar a little bit a little bit but
that's how we went to okay thank you
yeah right do you think they look like
family nutrition uh no they're not
family
things running a circle yeah right
exactly we've seen a lot of pictures
together so confused i'm trying to
figure out is that harvey weinstein or
this is harvey weinstein that one sorry
about it they kind of look like though a
little bit yeah yeah i don't know which
one are you familiar with either yes no
both i gotta say it takes balls to go up
to his people and ask about harvey
weinstein yeah no seriously i commend
her on that
thing
it's not like a normal prank you're
talking about harvey weinstein yeah you
know what she's doing the lord's work we
appreciate her definitely
okay well i was wondering if you think
they look similar or not at all
this guy knows who ryan cavanaugh is
this one that she's talking to right now
wait for real yeah hey let me go back
are you familiar with either
yes no
how does he know ryan
it just he must be there you go ryan's a
public figure okay well i was wondering
if you think they look similar or not at
all
[Music]
because i'm comparing the
their background and facial similarities
have anything to do with um
yeah corruptness exactly right probably
the beard but the beard
he said it corruptness
are you a fan of either
no neither neither medium upper lip
medium upper lip oh that's a good
analysis
that's interesting
medium upper lip
across people with no upper lip
questionable with this yeah the smile
it's like why are you grinning so much
you know yeah right
the eyes right thank you and here's a
sticker of the comparison just for
helping me out with that thank you
questions
i'm so confused you know that's harvey
weinstein or fastball rewind scene
that's probably why that's okay thank
you so much
i want to know if they're right that's
hardly weinstein or if that's harvey
weinstein that one okay they kind of
look alike i don't know who that is okay
yeah thank you do you know if that's
harvey weinstein or if that's harvey
weinstein i have no no they're not they
kind of look alike though right yeah a
little bit yeah
they do that's harvey weinstein or if
that's harvey weinstein
can you tell the difference
yeah of course you do you know yeah do
you know the other one no no but you
know which one's with right i was
wondering if you know who either these
people are
and he would uh produce yeah
yeah he's in jail now do you think that
they look similar
not really okay
i was gonna say supreme collection
ex-billionaire he used to um run
relativity media he was also like
accused of his ex-partner of running a
ponzi scheme doesn't look later
yeah retracted
should be clear like though not a little
no no okay i'm just informing the people
that these are two different people
[Music]
do you know who either of them are
harvey weinstein
ryan kavanagh but do they look similar
or not really normal no not at all good
good so you know that they're different
people yeah thank you letting people
know that these are two different people
do they look similar or not really
a little similar
the harvey weinstein kavanagh they look
kind of similar this is the strangest
interaction these people are gonna have
all year
they're gonna remember her
and think back on what the [ __ ] was that
thank you yeah yeah so i'm just taking
note from the public if they look
similar or not
so yeah yeah yeah okay thank you so much
after a long hard day of research the
public is still split until next
yeah she's right i mean that is actually
good
uh market research because
some were confused
some were not
but i do think it showed above all that
there is confusion out there
so shout out to love k-ray
who has been running ads on our channel
which i have to applaud that is a
it's an alpha move right there yep
definitely helpful
really meaning to watch that one there
fantastic fantastical
all right
well
good
times good time
we're gonna have good
times good times
we're gonna have good times
what you eating i'm hungry a danish with
some
she's dana schweller really are we all
eating danish yeah you want a danish
look at about it you want one
baby
we'll put in the time stamps in uh in
the episode this will be the chew zone
section what is what's the story with
the chris with the danishes
amantha brought him in samantha yeah
but did she buy it or did i buy it
okay
you got so thank you to me
[Music]
hmm
a little stale on the edges but pretty
good
it's that ralph's yet
oh a napkin wow i'm unworthy service
with a smile
you guys like danishes
i'm gonna do them i don't eat them often
enough though i never like think to go
for a danish but if they're around i'm
like oh yeah i like these
yep
that's how i feel what's your favorite
pastry
hmm
chocolate chip dana ganache
chocolate chip cash yeah
you know what i love lately is the
almond croissants
oh yeah those are dangerous but the
almond filling oh wow
unbelievable
we've lately been uh
having these um
like
it's like a
from a chinese uh bakery
make these like sweet rolls i don't know
what they're called i just like see them
but they come like individually wrapped
hmm i look it up
i'm not sure what you're talking about
hmm
oh marking summons
for real
is he live tweeting the show
[Music]
he said that's
sorry i don't know if you want you're
showing it on this yeah
bro you're such a fan bro here they look
like this they're like remember for 24
months
i've never seen that before these big
sweet rolls and then they're always they
have filling in them um there's
sometimes like savory fillings but then
sometimes it's like fruit or various
other things were really good hmm
no another youtuber dm me the pick and
told me what he did i don't watch his
lame show yeah right bro okay remember
for 30 months dude
i mean
he's just he's a tier three sub we've
literally seen screenshots
or in videos where he like accidentally
showed that the podcast was on the tv in
the background so he literally hasn't
got a [ __ ] dude that's like
label something like bring down h3 or
something
like
the real reason he hates him me i'll be
honest
i never admit it but
i think he really just wants to be my
friend oh i thought like genuinely not
jealous
no i thought because you're jewish is
what you were gonna
think he really just likes me and wants
to be my friend and he's so hurt that i
don't like him
there's definitely a situation with a
lot of these guys for sure like a romeo
juliet
haha there's someone that on the show
now your tweet what a [ __ ]
they claim the picture was doctrine he's
so mad he's like my skin isn't that bad
they claim to pick was doctored so they
tried to do it on your pick to prove you
can make anyone ugly
in real time they applied the sharpening
and it did nothing to your skin
so he just dumped on himself even harder
what a [ __ ]
this is great
keep it going guys
just a
reminder of how the photo looked
this is definitely altered
i don't care man it's just funny i love
these girls
yeah i mean what the [ __ ] who are you
unless
did i miss a part where you're like
natural yeah
we rub dirt all over and aged a few
years
just like yeah exactly
i don't care i mean
my hair looks good though
that hair looks hella good
well except again it's like deep fried
but yeah yeah he deep fried me bro
he says i opted my photo oh look at that
here ian just put it's side by side yeah
what the [ __ ] yeah that looks yeah
that's not edited
bro you got like [ __ ] yoda's forehead
i'm like green
[ __ ] i [ __ ] up
your [ __ ] job it says it's altered
can you believe this guy he dumped on
himself what a [ __ ]
so keemstar is actually watching now in
twitter
oh he is yeah should he call in
you know we should go home
we'll be going almost three hours oh
[ __ ] dude nuke drama dropped putin is
canceled you guys
no
breaking news on dramaalert
putin is cancelled you guys no way
beyond parody dude
this is crazy hashtag dramaalert
wait you said it oh i thought he was
still tweeting about it yeah he is he
replied to himself
he's fighting himself
keemstar not got this much attention and
keemstar has not got this much attention
since uh
since the firehouse
there's so many ways i could go with
that and they're all bad yeah they're
all bad
happy birthday keem
okay but now i was curious so i did
click and his shell and the dude is
stuffing his face with cookies
oh it's a danish it's a danish and it's
the only time i've ate
by the way look at the photo you took
does it look like the one that you
posted
you dumb [ __ ] it looks a little
different i look pretty normal there
bro you literally eat maple syrup out of
a plate with a fork so like
where's your daddy come on now
who eats maple syrup with a fork you
[ __ ] animal yeah you
yeah it tastes like beef by the way look
at my skin here okay
right
look at my skin here he says it's edited
he just dumped on himself
what an idiot
dude
you're almost 40 come on man get your
[ __ ] together
[Laughter]
seven days away from 40.
putin is canceled everybody hey did you
hear what putin did he's cancelled
dramaalert
hey you hear what's going on ukraine
it's crazy
is like a bad guy
it's cancelled
anyway
keemstar
irredeemable
degenerate oh yeah this is so good
breaking putin orders russian invasion
of eastern ukraine hashtag dramaalert
drama
yo did you guys hear the drama putin's
attacking ukraine
in other news dixie dimilio is dating
noah back the drama's crazy today
anyway fun fun times
we're having too much fun here on the h3
podcast are we not folks
he's cancelled
[Applause]
i love his thumbnails now look at this
[ __ ] watch it look at this
liar predator
why is he calling aiden ross a predator
i thought they were homies
not after that stream
another thing
we can't stop staying around the office
especially zach
yo i heard you're in trouble
i think you're in trouble
crypto [ __ ]
[ __ ]
so good that crypto [ __ ]
this is just horrible click bait look
you've got jeffree star wants to box
logan paul it's like obviously not
that's bad clock babe bro learn
40 years on this earth and you sold it
on a clickbait
yo we can't russia is cancelled wait
that's the title no
i was joking it's actually called
russia's cancelled
you guys he titled his show russia is
cancelled
no
i haven't spotted two different ways to
in the title and the thumbnail wait what
it's spelling differently it says
cancelled with one l on the thumbnail
hey come on
but i'm the number one supporter of
cancel culture
right that's undeniable
all right let's wrap it up here just
having too much fun with keemstar
the court gesture
well the court
jesters are actually known for being
wise
bruh you dead ass watching his live
stream someone said and he liked it
someone said keem took the extra l and
canceled
that's good
all right keemstar is like all right
listen i gotta go my girlfriend's
finishing high school
i gotta pick her up we gotta date a
chuck e cheese she loves the pizza
she plays in the balls she plays in the
ball but i sit and watch
i'm too old for the ball pit but she
loves it
it's crazy they serve alcohol at chuck e
cheese
she eats the cheese pizza i have a beer
you should see my girl play skeep ball
what is it called skee-ball it's just
skee-ball
you should see my girl play skee-ball
she's nuts
i i won her like 20 erasers from chuck e
cheese
it was such a good night
she's not old enough to drink that's why
we like going to chuck e cheese i can
drink and she plays in the ball pit
you should see my girlfriend run around
the jungle gym at chuck e cheese she's
super fast
my girl loves the animatronic show at
chuck e cheese
i'd like to take her there on friday
night it's our favorite date night
hey i gotta go my girlfriend's finishing
school i promised her i'd take her to
dave and buster's oh wait she's not old
enough i guess we'll go to chuck e
cheese
dave buster's 21 up right
i think so we should go there we were
talking about i want to go to dave and
buster's and i want to go to
the what the [ __ ] you call that place in
l.a southern saddle ranch sweeney land
oh
what is that it's another meme around
the office what's sweeney you know the
girl from before you sydney sweeney oh
yeah yeah why does she go there
no no swinging lane is a made-up place i
forgot who originated it but
yeah you guys are into sweeney it's a
magical land i've heard
i had to recently close them
closed she got engaged
really
[Laughter]
hey i like to go to uh i take my girl to
chuck e cheese kids eat free
[Applause]
hang on i gotta go pick up my girls
friday night let's get seed free at the
olive garden
i get the risotto she gets the mac and
cheese with french fries
and chicken nuggets she loves it
dave and busters is 21 and over that's
awesome we got to go there
you could go under 21 if you have a
guardian who is over 25.
my girl i can actually take my girl to
dave and busters now i can act as her
guardian
hey
am i still her guardian if i'm having
sex with her
i gotta check with the i gotta check
with the door am i still a guardian if
i'm having sex with her oh okay
they said that's okay
[Laughter]
hey it's woody allen night at dave and
busters
i gotta pick up my girl get right over
that's when you got when you when you
guardian for for your partner
and then you bring them up and i'm safe
with them
that's woody allen knight at dave and
busters
hey did i mention that ethan looks old
ethan looks very old
anyway i gotta go pick up my my
girlfriend
because school's finishing early today
and we're gonna go play mini golf it's
her favorite activity
imma get drunk and hit balls onto the
freeway she thinks it's super cool
[Applause]
all right
well we've had enough fun huh
hey i got to pick up mike
super old ethan looks so old
hey i gotta go pick up my girl
school finishing early on friday
we're gonna go mini biking in my
backyard
and guess what we don't check ids at my
bar
hey
somebody donated two dollars just said
ethan go play elden ring
yeah
woody alan that was funny
hey it's our kelly night at my house
that means we go to my basement bar
and i leave by myself
hey
throw it back up ian did you notice how
old ethan looks anyway i gotta go pick
up my daughter and my girlfriend at the
same time
they're in the same class together
oh sorry girlfriend the guardians can't
be i can't sleep with the guardian
so you gonna have to not come on this
date with us all right bye guys see you
on friday
[Music]
so
you